Tim Ferriss: Justin, it is nice to see you.
Very nice to see you again.
Justin Gary: Yeah, Tim.
Great to see you again as well.
Tim Ferriss: And you are at maybe undisclosed,
or you could disclose, but you are overseas
at the moment, so we are across the pond or
many ponds, as it were.
I'm glad we were able to make the timing work
and I thought we could begin with Magic.
So, Magic.
Magic: The Gathering is a game that I never
really became familiar with because I was
older guard at that point, Dungeons & Dragons,
a lot of the very first editions.
But my younger brother, on the other hand,
really became immersed in Magic and actually
competed on some level and his friends were
just obsessed with Magic: The Gathering.
So could you, please, for people who don't
have the context, explain what Magic is and
I suppose how you became involved and what
that trajectory looked like?
Justin Gary: Magic is a trading card game
invented by Richard Garfield.
And so what trading card game means is that
you can buy it, not just like a normal game
like Monopoly, you'd buy it in a store, it'd
be a single box here.
Here, you buy packs of cards like you would
baseball cards, and each one has different
gameplay elements.
The way I like to describe it for people who
don't know is it's sort of a cross between
chess and poker where you get to decide what
deck of cards you're going to play and what
pieces you get to play with.
So there's the poker element of I'm drawing
a hand of cards and maybe I can bluff what
I have and you don't know.
And there's the chess element of there's tactically,
once I play those cards, there's tactically
ways I use them that kind of battle back and
forth.
Then, of course, it has fantasy characters
and so it appeals to people who like Dungeons
& Dragons so you'll be playing wizards and
dragons and warriors and stuff like that.
I first got involved with Magic in a pretty
funny way, actually.
So I used to be on a competitive laser tag
league.
So I am a very, a very competitive person
by nature.
I've been involved in pretty much whatever
I do, I'll find some way to compete with it.
In between games of laser tag, people were
playing this card game that looked really
cool I'd never heard of before.
I watched them play and I was like, "Okay,
what is that?"
Okay, so I go to the store and I just buy
a pack of cards and, as I mentioned, the cards
are totally random.
So I just took all the random cards I bought
and just went to go play and I got my butt
kicked and was, of course, okay, you actually
have to construct and build your deck and
build your strategy and that helps it come
to life.
So I came back the next week and, okay, now
I played a little better and a little better
and eventually, at one point, all the guys
from my group were all going to go to a state
championship tournament.
Tim Ferriss: And how old were you at this
point?
Justin Gary: I was 16 years old.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
Justin Gary: So I was a young kid, so I was
like, "Oh, hey, come along.
Come on the car ride."
And those were some of my best memories in
general.
Just a bunch of guys hanging out, jumping
in the car and just talking about games, riding
up.
As it turns out, I won that tournament and
so I ended up becoming the state champion
and that got me an invitation to the national
championships.
Again, I was not ever taking this sort of
seriously, I wasn't even intending to go.
In fact, I was supposed to go to debate camp
that summer.
Yet another thing I was arbitrarily competitive
in.
And it ended up being my parents couldn't
afford to send me that year to debate camp.
So last minute, again, my friends were all
super supportive here, I ran a tournament
at my local game store.
They let me run the event.
I collected the entry fees from that tournament.
I used that to pay for a plane ticket to fly
to Columbus, where the US National Championships
was happening.
I slept on a friend's floor.
I was now 17 at this time and I ended up winning
the US National Championships and that ends
up taking me on a career of traveling around
the world, playing Magic for a living.
Tim Ferriss: So let's dive into a bunch of
things that you mentioned.
I was not aware of the debate camp component,
the debating piece, and I have watched debates.
I have never been part of a debate team.
Could you just explain for folks what a debate
competition looks like, or a debate as a game,
per se?
What does that look like and why were you
good or at least competent at it?
Justin Gary: There's a few different categories.
I'll just talk about my favorite one, it was
called Lincoln-Douglas debate at the time.
It basically means that you have a topic that
you're debating like, say, the US should have
closer relationships with China or it's better
to sacrifice the good of a few for the good
of the many or something like that, some topic.
And then you would have to pick one side of
the argument.
There's a judge in the room and you have a
certain amount of time to make your case.
Then the other person has a certain amount
of time to make their case.
Then you have some time for rebuttal and they
have some time for rebuttal.
At the end, the judge or judges would then
decide who won.
So that's kind of the outline.
Tim Ferriss: And there's a coin toss to decide
who goes first?
Justin Gary: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Because that seems like a major
advantage.
All right, so there's a —
Justin Gary: Well —
Tim Ferriss: Go ahead.
Justin Gary: It varies, right?
So from round to round, you'll go first or
second and this was sort of how we did it
in high school.
My favorite version of debate was what I did
in college, which was called parliamentary
debate where you could, literally, make up
any topic you wanted and just start talking
about it and the other side would have to
defend the other side.
You would just play and have fun and try to
figure out and convince people that this was
the way to go.
It was such a fun exercise in just persuasion
and kind of tactically how you wanted to frame
everything.
It became something I really spent quite a
bit of time on and really enjoyed.
Then it ended up being very useful for quite
a few things later in life.
It turns out being able to speak good has
value.
Tim Ferriss: So if we look at, say, the Lincoln-Douglas
format or the parliamentary, I suppose the
former is maybe a better example to use here,
knowing nothing about it.
But how much time do you have to prepare?
Once you are assigned or have chosen one side
of, let's just say, the US should have closer
ties with China and you're either pro or con.
How much time do you have to prepare that?
And are you just basically making it up, but
you're using the strength of your logic that
you construct, even if your assumptions are
off to defeat your opponent?
How does that work?
Justin Gary: So for those formats, the same
topic will hold for a while, for months, like
a season, and so you can prepare very much
ahead of time.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Got it.
Justin Gary: Then there's other ones that
like the parliamentary one, where you have
no idea what you're going to talk about until
you start going up there a lot of the times.
So that was more fun because it was a little
bit more extemporaneous, so there's varying
degrees.
So when you have the same topic over and over
again, you'd start to notice common threads
about how people will present it.
Then some people would, you'd try crazy things.
So may be that the US should have closer ties
with China and you would take a position,
actually the US should not exist anymore,
it should dissolve.
And you start making arguments around that
and you just kind of have to take the argument
seriously, in a sense, because the job of
the judge is to sort of leave outside their
preconceived notions and just hear what you
have to say.
So that, having to think on your feet and
react and be able to kind of come up with
unique answers and change the flow of things
was really quite a bit of fun.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so in that, I will move
on.
To everybody listening, I will move on in
a moment, but I really want to understand
this because I suspect, as you mentioned,
that these are threads that tie into other
things later, at least some of them.
These are not isolated skills.
If you're practicing, say, the parliamentary
style and you are developing this approach
to structured thinking and presenting and
you don't know what you're going to be speaking
about until you really sort of get on the
stage and somebody hands you the mic, it's
a sort of freestyle rap battle.
When you get up and then you give your spiel,
how do the judges judge?
What does that look like?
Justin Gary: Great question.
So —
Tim Ferriss: Because presumably they might
not know anything about the topic that you're
discussing, so they can't really fact-check
a lot of what you're saying, I would assume.
Justin Gary: That's right.
There's no live fact-checking in these formats,
it's about your persuasive ability.
If I were going to break this down into kind
of core skillsets and what the judges are
doing, which is also what I'm doing as a competitor,
is any time my opponent is saying something,
I'm writing down their points.
So I'm breaking them down into kind of concrete
notes and I want to make sure that for each
point that's brought up, I am addressing it
in some key way.
Now a lot of times I can make some broader
point that will maybe take out a few of their
points.
And because you only have a certain amount
of time, how efficiently are you able to use
that time to both refute the points that they're
saying, as well as bring up your own points
that are hopefully harder to refute.
So it becomes a kind of process of being very
good at listening and taking notes.
Then being able to structure how do you want
to set up your replies so that you're gaining
time advantage, if you will, with your persuasive
ability to give you more time to make your
own row of arguments so that hopefully they
don't have time in their thing to properly
address and attack everything.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, great.
So, as promised, I'm going to move forward
in the chronology.
Justin Gary: This is great.
I've never been asked about this before, so
this is fun.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm trying to do my job
as best I can.
Returning to Magic.
So you mentioned that led to all these adventures
traveling around the world, competing.
What does that mean?
Could you explain what that looks like in
terms of incentives, stakes, how profitable
is it for someone to be a full-time Magic
player?
I imagine it depends on the person, but what
does it mean to travel around the world and
compete?
Justin Gary: So now, we're taking this back
now.
Date myself a little bit.
But this is '97 when I won the US National
Championships and the core of my career was
about the six years from '97 to about 2003.
That time there was what was called the Magic
Pro Tour, which was put on by the company
that made the game as a way to promote it
and they would have millions of dollars of
prizes available.
So at any given tournament you could win.
So my biggest tournament winnings would typically
be in the $30,000 range.
So a pro tour in Houston where I won that
or these different tournaments.
So to give you a sense, a first place in one
of those tournaments was $30,000-ish all the
way down till top 32, maybe you'd get a thousand
dollars.
Then you'd have to get invited to these tournaments.
There'd be maybe 300 people-ish that would
get invited.
So I would do a tournament in Prague.
Then there'd be another one in Sydney.
Then there'd be another one in Seattle.
There'd be another one in Tokyo and so we
got to literally just meet up.
And again, I'm in high school, I'm a teenager,
so this is just like crazy.
Tim Ferriss: It's a lot of money.
Justin Gary: Oh, my god, it's crazy money,
right?
So I was just, such a fun thing.
But when you think about it as an adult, it's
not a crazy, crazy amount of money, but it
was great at the time.
You can't win every tournament, but when I
was playing at my peak, it was maybe $80,000
a year I was making, so it's still not —
Tim Ferriss: That's no joke for a teenager?
Justin Gary: At that time, it was great.
I mean, it's how I paid my way through college.
So it was better than flipping burgers, I'll
put it that way.
Tim Ferriss: What was your major in college?
Justin Gary: I was a philosophy major.
Tim Ferriss: How did you choose philosophy?
Justin Gary: Well, as you might guess, I love
debating.
I mean, I've always been very interested in
just sort of talking about the deep questions,
trying to get down to the fundamentals of
what is interesting and what matters.
I tried a few different majors in history
and I was on my path to be a lawyer because
my parents are lawyers and that's what I thought
I was supposed to do.
But I found most classes, when I went to them,
the job as a student in the class was to regurgitate
whatever it was that the professor told you
back to them and that bored the hell out of
me.
Whereas in philosophy, the job was to make
a reasonable argument.
It didn't matter, just like in debate, it
didn't matter what your position was, is can
you defend it?
Do you have good logic for it?
And to try to, I loved being proven wrong.
I loved when I would have, I think there was
something, this was a kind of strength and
a weakness.
I loved debating with people and I loved it
when someone told me something I didn't know
or convinced me I was wrong.
I was like, "That's amazing.
That's great."
It took me a very long time to realize most
people are not like that.
In high school I was voted most likely to
disagree with anything you say.
So I learned to be a little bit more cautious
and compassionate in my conversations with
people, but I really enjoyed it.
So philosophy let me explore that space of
really what matters in the world and what
matters to me and really refine my thinking
and get challenged on my thinking when I was
unclear or fuzzy.
Tim Ferriss: I want to mention for people
who may not notice this pattern that on this
podcast there is disproportionate representation
of former philosophy majors, however, that
could be severe survivorship bias.
I'm sure there are many, many philosophy majors
who do not end up on large podcasts.
However, it is notable to me.
You have people who are deeply interested
in philosophy who also end up in these conversations
with me.
Reid Hoffman would be another example who,
I'm not sure if he majored in philosophy,
but he has taught philosophy and takes it
very, very seriously.
Why were you comfortable and maybe even invigorated
by being proven wrong or converted in that
way?
Did that come from being raised in a family
of lawyers?
Did it come from something else?
What contributed to that?
Justin Gary: Yes.
I think there's two factors here.
I think one, you're absolutely right.
My parents were wonderful in the sense that
as a kid, I could argue my way to a later
bedtime or I could argue my way to, "Hey,
if I finished my homework, I can get an extra
setting of dessert," or whatever.
They encouraged if I could kind of debate
my way to something, then I could get it and
so it trained me very young.
And similarly, my dad and I, we would be playing
cutthroat games of Monopoly around the kitchen
table quite a bit.
But they did, they reinforced that after the
game, what did you learn?
If you lost, what did you learn from it?
And that's the biggest thing that I credit
for, certainly my success in Magic, and I've
tried to apply that everywhere else in my
life is that when you lose, which you inevitably
are going to lose in life.
It doesn't matter what it is that you look
first to, "Okay, what could I have done differently?
How could I have set this up differently so
that I wouldn't even be in this position?"
It's easy when you're playing a game like
Magic where your opponent draws a lucky card.
It's a one out of 60 that they draw that card
and they beat you because of it.
And you'd hear in the hallways, other people
would be complaining about what's called bad
beats, right?
"I got unlucky.
Oh, my God."
But the best players wouldn't do that.
The best players would say, "Actually, if
five turns earlier I had made this different
play, it wouldn't have mattered what card
they drew at that turn."
That skillset was something that was drilled
into me, and it's something I definitely credit
quite a bit of success across a variety of
fields.
Tim Ferriss: This might seem a strange question,
but do Magic competitors — or did they study
games in the way that chess players study
historic games of chess where those moves
and decisions are recorded in some way?
I'm not sure if it lends itself to that.
Justin Gary: Oh, it absolutely does.
And people would break these things down.
So again, we're going to take ourselves in
the way back machine, '97, '98.
This era, the internet is still relatively
new, right?
Still relatively light and so people would
go to what at the time was called the Magic
Dojo, which you can now find in the internet
archives.
It was where everybody would post tournament
reports of, "Okay, here's what I played, here's
what happened."
And people would comment on them and break
down kind of more classic bulletin board style.
That's where the core of Magic strategy and
discussion started to form.
And now there's dozens of sites and dozens
of places where you can find this.
But it was unlike with chess where people
have been doing this strategy and breaking
down games for hundreds of years, Magic's
30 years old or whatever and at the time it
was very new.
And so I got to see the origins of these strategies
come together and break down individual games
and individual moves, and it became obsessive.
I mean, if you look at my old college notebooks,
they are covered in Magic deck ideas and scribbles,
and at least as much as there are notes about
philosophy or whatever it was I was supposed
to be studying.
Tim Ferriss: What were the main innovations?
If you had to try to identify some game design
elements that led to or contributed to Magic
becoming such a global phenomenon, what would
you say were the innovations?
I mean, there's definitely the slot machine,
dopamine potential of buying these packs just
like buying baseball cards, right?
But what else is there in the game that made
it at least have the possibility of exploding
in the way that it did?
Justin Gary: So there's a lot of factors.
There's a deep answer, but we have a long-form
podcast, so if you don't mind.
Tim Ferriss: I love deep answers.
Take all the time you want.
Justin Gary: I teach game design and there's
sort of five major categories of what people
are looking for out of games and Magic hits
all of them in ways.
So I'll talk about the categories first and
then I'll talk about why Magic succeeded in
such an incredible way.
So the first is immersion.
You're looking for certain experiences or
you're looking to craft a story.
The second is connection, right?
You're looking to socialize, you want help
other people, you want to connect with others.
The third is aspiration.
This can be in competition, this can be achievements.
You want to win, you want to prove you're
better than, prove you can achieve something.
Then the fourth is growth.
You want to learn, you want to continue to
move up and improve your skills.
And the last is expression.
This idea that you want to customize or role
playing works this way because we express
different parts of ourselves through role
playing.
And so those are kind of the major categories.
I think Magic allowed people to both not only
have these competitions like I was doing,
but it allowed people to customize and grow
in a world where it's infinitely deep.
At a certain point with chess, it's a deep
game, but there's only so many pieces.
I can learn them all.
I can know kind of the frame I'm playing it.
With Magic, there's constantly new cards coming,
there's constantly new things to do, and I
get to own, I get to customize and own my
experience.
So to relate it to something you're more familiar
with, Dungeons & Dragons, the idea that you
get to tell the story, that you get to create
the character is so powerful and so immersive
and Magic is very similar.
If you want to build a deck with all elf cards,
you could do that.
If you want to build a deck that has every
card that you could imagine and is 300 cards
deep, you can do that.
If you want to be the hyper competitive, hyper-focused
guy, you could do that.
There are so many experiences that you get
to, in a sense, design your own game.
And it's one of the things that I've learned,
much like you talked about, a lot of philosophy
majors end up on your podcast, a lot of the
game designers started from a game like Magic
or Dungeons & Dragons.
Because as you play, you're crafting your
own experience, and I think that was such
a unique and powerful thing.
Dungeons & Dragons could be a little intimidating
for people because it's so open-ended.
Tim Ferriss: No, it's so intimidating.
It's so complex.
Or at least it can be.
Justin Gary: It can be.
Tim Ferriss: It's a real commitment.
Exactly.
Whereas Magic, you're playing inside of these
box and these rules, but once you start exploring
it, then this whole world opens up.
I think that was really the "magic" of it,
and it really made it feel like something
that was very new and spawned an entire genre
of games.
Tim Ferriss: And I remember at one point,
I think it was certainly at the time, I think
TSR, I was reading this book called, I believe
it's Art & Arcana.
Or arcana.
I'm not sure how you pronounce that word properly,
even though I've read it a thousand times,
which is a visual history of Dungeons & Dragons.
And at some point they realized one of the
major stumbling blocks was people having to
develop from scratch their own characters.
And they provided out-of-the-box templates,
which was one of the ways they jump started
wider adoption.
It's giving people an easy place to start
with some type of positive constraints, let's
just say, in a sense.
That makes me think about Magic.
Now, can you remind me and listeners of who
developed Magic?
Justin Gary: So Richard Garfield was the lead
designer.
He created the game along with of course a
lot of other people that supported, but he
was the lead, the creator.
Tim Ferriss: I remember listening to, and
you're going to have to fact-check me on this,
but I think I'm recalling this correctly,
listening to at least one, maybe two interviews
with Richard on your podcast, Think Like a
Game Designer.
He was talking about game development, and
I guess folks who were auditing the cards
and the decks and the idea that some cards
would get retired or removed from circulation
or banned because they were too powerful.
But if there were no cards that were too powerful
that they were also erring on the side of
caution, something along those lines.
Could you expand on what I'm very clumsily
trying to recall from an interview I listened
to a year ago?
Justin Gary: So there's this idea in games
of balance, which is a very, it's a term that
people throw around a lot but gets very confused.
And the principle of it is that you don't
want some part of your game to be so unfair
that you can't, nobody can beat you.
So if it's in Tic-Tac-Toe, if you get to make
three moves at once, that would be pretty
unfair.
The game is already over.
You got your three in a row, that doesn't
make any sense.
So the game's no fun.
So the idea is you want to make sure that
there's no one strategy that's too good.
But some people think that that means everything
needs to be exactly the same and that's also
not true because the idea, if every card is
just as equally good as every other card,
then you deny people that discovery.
You deny people that ability to learn and
say, "Oh, wait, hold on."
As a new player you don't know anything.
And then you can learn, oh, actually, you
know what?
This card's better than this card.
Or the excitement of chasing and finding something
that's very exciting that now you can combine
with something else that you have and suddenly
that gets better.
And so the way I define balance is not everything
has to be equal.
It's that everything, there's no one strategy
that should be unbeatable.
The best analogy is if you think Rock-Paper-Scissors.
Perfectly balanced game.
Rock is great, but if I know you're going
to throw rock, I've got a plan.
I could throw paper and I'm going to be okay.
So there's a lot of ways that you can approach
balance, but that can give you a sense of
what it should look like.
And so for Richard, he wanted to make things
that were exciting and chase and you're really
hoping you open up in a pack.
Of course, he didn't have any idea that the
game was going to be as popular as it was.
He talked about in the podcast episode that
he thought you would just never even see all
the cards.
That some people would have a couple of packs
and other people would have a couple of packs,
and you just discovered as you went.
And that is actually, it's an exciting prospect
but very quickly people would buy all the
cards.
Now there's spoilers on the internet and everybody
sees everything immediately.
So it's changed a lot since his initial concept.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so as the next lily
pad, I want to explore one of two things.
We're going to get to both so you can choose
which you think makes sense to talk about
first.
So the first option is your path to where
you are now as a senior partner at a law firm.
Just kidding.
So law school.
The other is what happened in your Magic life
after winning the nationals and that story?
So which of those do you think makes sense
to tackle first?
Justin Gary: Well, I think let's start —
Tim Ferriss: Or you can imagine, or you could
talk about both in tandem.
Either one, either or.
Justin Gary: We'll go in chronology order
so that the Magic career kind of has its arc
before my law career has its much shorter
arc.
So I'm 17 years old, I win the US National
Championships.
This was a huge, awesome, cool thing for me.
But then I go to the world championships and
at that point in Magic's life cycle, the US
was dominant.
The US had never lost a world championships
ever.
And not just me, but a team of people that
were representing the US and unfortunately
we did not win.
We did not do very well.
So that world championships, I had this albatross
around my neck of being the first loser US
National Champion.
At least this is the story I was telling myself.
So I was like, "Okay, this is not great."
And my career was good, I was doing good,
but it was something that always stuck with
me and so I kept wanting to try to get back
on the national team to redeem myself.
So fast forward five years later.
Finally the US loses again.
Loses to the Germans.
So now I'm not the only loser.
Not that I was rooting against the US, but
it was nice to not be the only loser.
And then the very next year I make it back
on the US National Team.
And so this is my chance, my chance at redemption.
After six years, and I'm with two other people
on the team and the two people that are on
the team with me, they were pretty new to
the game.
They kind of had come out of nowhere just
like I did when I first started, and I was
so committed to making sure we did well.
I paid to fly both of them to Boston where
I was living at the time, to stay at my place
and work.
And we trained for a month, a month and a
half together with my team, who was Your Move
Games was the local store and group we would
playtest with.
So we trained, we slept on my couch, we worked
together to be able to make it back.
That year, the world championships were in
Berlin.
So we're going into enemy territory and it
comes down to literally we make it to the
final table, to the final game.
It comes down to me playing this match and
we've got stage lights, we're covering it.
This is everything I have worked for.
There's some online records of the experience
but I remember just sort of feeling in that
moment that — I'd been in tournaments, I'd
won tournaments, I'd lost tournaments.
There's a certain amount of excitement and
pressure.
But for this one, it was so much of a personal
story, a personal kind of drama that I was
playing out for me.
And I drew my hand the first time for this
final match where everything's on the line,
people are watching.
There's a rule in Magic where if you don't
like your hand, if you don't like the starting
cards you have, you can take a mulligan.
And what that means is you throw the cards
away, but you get one less card and it's a
big deal.
Less cards is a huge disadvantage in the game.
But I draw my hand and I'm trying to make
this decision, and I'm just, "All right, do
I deal with what I have or do I just take
a shot?"
And I didn't like the hand.
I wasn't going to take a shot.
I wasn't going to let the world championships
be decided on that hand.
So I mulligan, throw the cards away.
My teammates are groaning in the background
just like, "All right, here we go."
Shuffle up, draw the hand.
And it becomes one of those moments where
you kind of see it come together.
The hand was good enough.
We start playing it out.
I get some board advantage.
My opponent's kind of on his back foot and
he's got a couple tricks.
There's some cards I have to play around,
I'm not really sure.
And then finally I'm able to get to the point
and win this fight after however long people
rush the stage, able to finally take that
off of my back.
And it was a very exciting moment for me.
It was a very fun journey, and it was a result
of a lot of hard work.
It was a lot of dedication that got there,
but it kind of felt, for me that it was the
end of my Magic career.
It was the thing that I had, I had been striving
to do that.
I kind of checked those boxes and that was
kind of like, let me move to this next stage.
Tim Ferriss: So before we get to your short
arc in the world of law, was there something,
coming back to your previous comment that
you learned after losing on the world championship
stage first, was there something you learned
or decided to change about your approach after
that?
Justin Gary: I think that this is, now we're
talking about years of gap in between.
And so what I did learn and the major thing
that I realized in that Magic is generally
a single-person game.
I'm playing a match against somebody else
in competition.
But in this case, it's a team game.
And I think the biggest shift in focus was
I didn't just think about myself.
I had to think about how do I lift everybody
else up and all thrive together to be able
to make it through.
And it really changed the way I focused there,
changed the way I focused with other teams
I've worked with.
It made a huge impact.
And then just being willing to, again, come
back from a loss and not let it discourage
you that you can't overcome it.
But I think that being able to work, typically
most of the games I've played have been single
player, whether it was debate or wrestling
or most of Magic, it was all about, "I'm here
to win."
And I think my shift in mindset was, "No,
I'm here for us to win."
And that was a really huge turnaround for
me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's a big, big shift
in terms of looking through the prism.
Tim Ferriss: So law school.
Justin Gary: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Tell us about law school.
Justin Gary: So just to frame this, right,
so I've already mentioned both of my parents
are lawyers, my mom's a lawyer, my dad's a
lawyer, my stepdad's a lawyer.
I was debate captain.
I was supposed to be a lawyer.
That was just my path from as early as I can
remember, that's what I was supposed to do.
And even though I had been making a living
and traveling around the world playing Magic,
at no point did it ever occur to me that I
would make a living in games, none.
It was just, oh, this is a fun thing to do
while I'm in college.
I had this mental block.
And so I graduate, go get into NYU Law.
I teach the LSAT for a while.
I go to law school and I'm lucky, I'm a pretty
happy guy by default.
But this was the first time I was really depressed.
I was very unhappy for an extended period
of time.
And I will remember very specifically, there's
one day I'm getting up in Brooklyn, snowing
outside, just covered in ice in the floor,
and I have to get trudged up, put on all of
these ridiculous clothes, and go to get on
the A train and pretend like I'm not staring
at anybody else.
So everybody has to studiously avoid looking
at anybody else in New York.
That's just the rule.
And make it all the way in.
Have my Boston cream donut for breakfast,
because that's just how I lived back then.
And I go into this NYU law library, which
is like, you know, could picture this just
cavernous, giant library with old oak and
towers of books.
It was back when you had to use books to learn
things.
It was a wild time.
And I checked out the law books I had to read
before class and I'm — stack them up, these
just towers around me, and I'm just there
and I'm there for hours just reading case
law and just not very happy.
But a couple of hours later I realized I've
got to get to class.
And so I sit up and I have this jolt of pain
through my spine, like, huh, jolt of pain.
I can barely move.
I'm hobbling to get out of there.
And I realize I threw my back out from reading,
from reading.
That is how unhealthy I was.
I was over about 40 pounds heavier than I
am now.
How just miserable I was.
And this was my first clue that I'm on the
wrong path.
And I think this is something I, it's a really
important lesson, I think.
I imagine there's a lot of overachievers in
your audience, and that this path of trying
to win whatever game's in front of you, it
can be way worse to win the wrong game than
even to lose one that you actually enjoy playing.
And that was a big shift for me.
And fortunately that summer I had an opportunity
to go, instead of interning at a law firm,
I got to go work on a Marvel Comics card game,
a Marvel versus DC Comics card game for a
company called Upper Deck in San Diego.
So summer internship, working on comic book
games instead of — that sounded great.
And so I flew across country to go and worked
there for the summer.
And again, even though I knew I was miserable,
even though I'd had this terrible experience,
even though I now had a kind of opportunity
in front of me still, my assumption at this
point was, I'm going to go back to law school,
I'm going to go back.
I've got to finish that path.
But I come out to start working on games and
I am in love with it.
I'm super passionate about it.
I'm enjoying it.
Again, we're debating these really interesting
ideas about design and definitely happy to
dig into what that looks like.
But then when they offer me a full-time job,
I'm still stressing about this.
And it's still finally when I make the decision,
I tell my mom, she literally cries when I
tell her I'm leaving law school to go become
a game designer.
It was so hard.
And I look back, and it's so silly to me.
"This is one of the things you've taught me."
I didn't have these words at the time, but,
"I learned it through you."
This idea of fear-setting where, in fact,
I wasn't really giving up anything.
I could always go back to law school, but
it just didn't feel like that at the time.
And so being able to break out of that spell
and then go follow a path that was really
passionate for me that I was really excited
about, one of the best decisions I ever made.
Tim Ferriss: How did you find the internship?
Justin Gary: So this was fortunate because
of my Magic career.
They had reached out to me to just vet their
game and try to check it out and stuff.
So some of the other people on the Magic Pro
tour who people who I'd known had already
kind of been hired there.
So they were like, "Hey."
And they knew I was miserable.
I would chat with them.
They're like, "Hey, come out for the summer,
come work on this thing.
You've got nothing to lose," kind of deal.
Tim Ferriss: Has your mom come around, or
is she still hoping for that day when you
return to law school?
Justin Gary: No, my mom has come around.
I'm sure she'll listen to this episode.
Hi, Mom.
She did.
And this is the thing, the people in our lives,
there's a lot of pressure that we all feel,
whether it's from parents, from friends, they
want the best for us.
So you just want us, me, to be happy and safe
and comfortable.
And you've got to realize that you, in order
to find the path that you actually want for
yourself, the path that you will be fulfilled
by, you've got to be uncomfortable.
You've got to be unsafe, right?
Parents, I think, try to protect their kids
so much and reality, you can't.
You've got to be able to push past that.
And she knows that now.
And she was very happy it all worked out.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
All right.
Well, we're going to fill in the gaps for
those people who aren't your mom listening.
Hi, Mom.
Since we have a lot to fill in and look now
I feel like I should defend your mom also,
certain paths are more predictable than others,
and there is the perception and maybe even
the reality of safety, consistency, stability
with certain choices.
But as you said, choosing the right game is
more important than winning the game that
just happens to be in front of you.
And at least certainly in my experience, in
the experience of a lot of people on this
podcast, and just because something is unpredictable
does not automatically make it unsafe.
It just makes it less certain.
And as you put it, many of these things, for
instance, I'll give you another example, and
this is very analogous.
When people invoke the names of, say, Zuckerberg
or someone else who dropped out as this throwing
caution to the wind, burning the boats behind
them to take the risk of entrepreneurship,
whenever possible, I try to point out that's
actually not the case for most people who,
say, take a leave of absence from a Harvard
or Stanford.
They can go back any time they want to go
back.
So it's —
Justin Gary: Yes, 100 percent.
100 percent.
And again, you've said this better than honestly
anybody, like this idea that most of the fears
that we have, this resistance to uncertainty
is just made up in our head that there's so
many ways that you could recover and go back
and that if you can — just remember that
I could have gone back to law school later
on when I quit my game design job to start
a company, I could always get another job.
Those things are those illusions of uncertainty
and fear.
If you can push past that, it changes everything.
I mean, most of the times we take risks, we're
not jumping off cliffs or into burning buildings.
It's just, okay, yeah, your career takes a
different path or you're behind in school
or whatever.
It's a very low cost.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Most often recoverable.
So I will, I'll link to fear-setting and people
can just search fear-setting, goal-setting
with a hyphen in it.
And all sorts of things will pop up if you
just search that or go to tim.blog/ted because
that was the topic of my TED Talk, I suppose
quite a few years ago now.
But moving on from fear-setting for a moment,
it might come back into the conversation,
who knows?
But what did that first year or six months,
month could be the first week, however you
want to frame it, of designing games look
like.
What was that experience like?
Justin Gary: Yeah, yeah.
So it's a really fun question because people
just make this assumption that because I was
good at playing games, then that means I would
be good at making games.
And they are 100 percent different skills.
I did not think of myself as a creative person
there, thought there was just some kind of
magic special secret sauce that other people
had, and I was just going to fake it and go
out there and see what happened.
And so when I go there, I'm having serious
imposter syndrome.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know how to make this come to life.
And I researched a ton.
I read some great books on creativity, A Whack
on the Side of the Head is one I'd recommend.
And I started to talk to other people who
I did respect as designers and kind of break
it down.
And over time I realized that there's nothing
that differentiates a creative person from
a not-creative person other than process.
And so as an analytically minded person, I
was able to break it down into what I call
the core design loop, which is a six-step
process of how do you create not just games,
but I think every creative field that applies
to.
And so learning that, and I was very lucky,
I'll talk about the details of it.
I won't leave you hanging on that piece, but
the experience being —
Tim Ferriss: I won't let you leave me hanging.
Go ahead.
Justin Gary: Just to immerse the experience
of it.
I was lucky in a sense in that I went to go
work at a company where I had a lot of friends
that were already there, and I had immediate
deadlines.
This game is going to release.
You have to turn over the file with the cards
and the things within two months you have.
And so there was no choice but to act.
So what I say is that deadlines are magic.
It doesn't matter if you have no idea what
you're doing, you have a deadline.
Tim Ferriss: I was literally going to just
say the exact same thing verbatim, and it's
like, what a beautiful constraint.
It's just remarkable what you get done.
Justin Gary: So that was, I think, a real
powerful tool about why.
So one, really short deadlines, and my job
was on the line, so I had stakes, right?
And I didn't want to go back to law school.
And two, that I had other people that I could
ask and talk to who were smarter than I was,
who had done it before, and I could get some
insight into.
So being able to find either books or mentors
or other people that you can talk to has also
helped accelerate it.
So that eventually turned into this kind of
step-by-step process.
So if you'd like, I can go into that now or
I can jump into other stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Actually before we get into the process, could
you explain why a A Whack on the Side of the
Head was impactful for you or what you took
from that that was valuable?
Because in the course of doing homework for
this conversation, I noticed that you had
mentioned this book before, and I actually
have a deck of cards designed by the same
author.
I have not read the book, however.
Could you speak to why that had an impact
or why you recommend it?
Justin Gary: So it's nice in that it helps
to, in a sense, demystify creativity and just
bring it down to a very kind of simple, granular
level.
And I'll give some examples.
So one of the principles in it is that I've
used all the time is basically, and I forget
how they word it in the book, but basically
turn the object around in your mind.
If you take something that you normally think
of one way, how many different ways can you
look at that same thing?
So if you have a pen, right?
You can say, all right, well, what do you
do with a pen?
Well, you can write with it.
Okay, well, no, all right.
I could use it to help force me to smile by
biting it.
I could use it to prop up my microphone.
I could use it.
You could, trying exercises that give you
different frames were very powerful and ways
to break you out of your thinking.
The idea of using random constraints.
So one of the exercises I encourage anybody
to do if they want to is if you're having
a problem, some creative challenge, some block,
go to a random book on your shelf, open it
to a random page and point to a random set
word, some substantive word.
Now, figure out how that word relates to whatever
your problem is, and journal on that for five
minutes, 10 minutes.
And you'll be amazed at how, all of a sudden,
it can crack open something because we get
so linearly focused on the problem in front
of us.
And even a completely random constraint can
open up the door for you.
And we'll give one more to just move past
the, quote unquote, right answer.
That you may have an answer and say, "Okay,
that's fine."
And then you stop.
Most people stop.
Instead say, "Okay, I'm going to look for
the third right answer, the fourth right answer,
the fifth," right?
"I'm going to look beyond that to go deeper
and find more things."
So just these little exercises.
And you could just do those exercises would
suddenly say like, "Oh, wow, okay.
I'm already seeing myself be more creative.
I'm already seeing myself do more than I was."
And so the book was impactful because it could
just, by the time I was done reading it, I
had already seen myself do creative things
I didn't think I could do in ways that sound
pretty stupid.
I'm sure to me, saying it, pick a random page
of a book, be more creative, trust me, try
it.
It works.
Tim Ferriss: Without having read that book,
I have used this approach.
And actually writing teachers that I had long
ago, back when I had hair and was in school,
also would offer these types of random constraints.
It's almost like the itching approach to creativity,
right?
It's like, okay, you just throw a bunch of
Scrabble tiles on the floor and you'd pick
the three that are closest to you, and that's
your constraint, or that's the filter in a
sense, or what directs the exercise.
Very, very powerful.
And I wanted to mention, since you were talking
about going past the right answer and finding
the third right answer actually reminded me
of something a former guest said, Derek Sivers,
who's one of my favorite people, he's been
on a few times.
And when I asked him who he thought of when
he heard the word "successful," he said, "Well,
my first answer might be, say, Richard Branson,
but that really ultimately depends on his
goals in life.
And if his goal was to have a quiet life undisturbed
by entrepreneurship, then that wouldn't be
successful.
So let me skip the first answer, get to the
second answer, get to the third answer."
And he said, "What you should ask people is,
'Who is the third person who comes to mind
when you hear the word successful?'"
And it's really a powerful heuristic that
you can use in all sorts of ways.
All right, so that's a snapshot on A Whack
on the Side of the Head.
Let's talk about the core loop.
Justin Gary: Yeah.
Before we jump into the core design loop,
I'm going to give one more thing.
It's not from A Whack on the Side of the Head,
but it's something I've actually developed
more recently as a process that I find super
valuable.
And one of the things that we try to do in
our company is always surface our assumptions.
There's a lot of things where you're assuming
a game is going to be fun because of this.
We assume people are looking for that.
We assume we're making this category of game,
et cetera.
And a really great exercise to do that's in
this spirit is once a quarter, we'll do an
assumptions challenging exercise.
And what that means is you surface every assumption
you can.
So if you're on a, you can do this by yourself,
or if you're on a team, everybody writes down
on their own all their assumptions, you put
them all up on a shared board or a shared
Google Doc if you're doing remote like we
are.
And then you, one by one, "Okay, what if that
weren't true?"
Or to use your terminology, "What if I did
the opposite?"
And it's so powerful because sometimes it
doesn't mean anything, right?
Sometimes it's like, okay, that doesn't make
any sense.
You move on.
But without fail, by the time we finish that
exercise, we find some core assumption that
all of a sudden changes everything.
And that ability to just take what you assume
to be true, one, making it explicit in the
first place is super powerful, just so you
know really what you're doing.
And then two is this inversion process is
incredibly powerful.
So, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Could you give any examples just
to make it a little concrete in the minds
—
Justin Gary: Yeah, absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: — of folks listening of what
those assumptions might be?
Justin Gary: I made this game called SolForge
with Richard Garfield, the guy that created
Magic.
And we did this over a decade ago, and we
made it as a digital trading card game.
And so purely you play it on your phone, no
physical objects at all.
And the game was successful.
We ran it for a few years, and eventually
we took it down and we were talking about
we wanted to bring it back because we loved
the game, we wanted to bring it back.
And one of the exercises we did, okay, SolForge
is a digital game.
And then we're like, wait, what if it's not?
Like, what would that look like?
And we had built it to be a digital game,
but then all of a sudden we're like, well,
now it's seven years later.
Digital printing technology is way better
than it was.
You can actually algorithmically create one-of-a-kind
cards and create things.
And that started us down this road of investigating
this new technology.
And so the new version of SolForge, called
SolForge Fusion, is now a physical card game
that has this new technology built into it,
which never would've happened if we had just
gone with our assumptions of, oh, okay, we're
going to remake the same game again.
So it's one example that was recently impactful
for me in this.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I love that.
I have, well, I can't tip my tip hand too
hard here publicly, but I've been very much
focused on possibly working on my first book
in five or six years.
It's been a long time.
I wasn't sure I would do another one, but
I've been very strongly considering it.
And I've been not in written form, which would
be more helpful, I think, but in a sort of
meandering mental form, which is sort of a
mix of reverie, skepticism, and daydreaming,
looking at some of the basic assumptions.
Is it a book?
I think of it as a book, but does it even
need to be a book, period, or I should say
question mark?
And if it is a book, for instance, generally
if you're going through the publishing process,
or you have been through the publishing process,
your thinking has been shaped in a certain
way over and over again.
You're like, okay, I have to do print, audio
ebook, and you sell all of those to one person.
Well, what if we split those up?
What if there was no print whatsoever?
What would that look like?
And just testing these very basic assumptions.
And I'll give you one example also, which
people might not realize, or if you're outside
of publishing, why would you realize this?
But none of my books in the US have ever gone
to paperback.
And if you were to ask most authors, "Why
have you gone to paperback?"
The answer would generally be something along
the lines of, "Well, the publishers always
do that.
A year and a half after the hardcover, they
lower the price to make the market larger
for the book.
And you come out in paperback."
And I was like, "But if you look at the math,
does that make any sense for you?"
And then they think about it and they're like,
"Well, let me think about that.
Okay.
I was making 15 percent on each hardcover
book, which is already discounted on Amazon
to something very affordable.
And now when I go to paperback, wait a second,
my royalties just got cut to seven and a half
or six and a half.
Now I have to sell twice as many books to
make the same amount in royalties.
Oh, shit, that makes no sense whatsoever."
It's also not really relevant in a world where
ebook is an option, if that makes any sense.
If somebody is looking for a lower price,
they can buy it on ebook.
So hence from the beginning, none of my books
have ever gone to paperback.
So if you're open to it, we can certainly,
I mean love, as you know, you know this very
well, I love digging into testing assumptions
because those are the rules that, that's like
the operating — your assumptions of the
operating system that governs your life in
a way.
Justin Gary: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: And you want to make sure want
to, those rules can be justified on some level,
but maybe it makes sense to hop into the core
design loop and talk about that.
Justin Gary: Yeah, it's perfect.
I think it's a perfect segue because exactly
what we're talking about with assumptions
is going to come into play in the core design
loop.
So the core design loop is how games are made,
it's how creative projects are done, but we're
going to focus on games.
That's the kind of main topic I teach at it.
So the core design loop is six steps.
It's inspiring, framing, brainstorming, prototyping,
testing, and iterating.
So step one is inspiring.
What is it that's driving you, right?
What's the core of what you're excited about?
So it could be you want to make a game for
this IP, this world that you love.
Could be you want to make a CØCKPUNCH game.
Could be want to make a game about fantasy
warriors, right?
Hypothetically speaking, it could be that
you want to —
Tim Ferriss: Or miniatures if you love miniatures.
Justin Gary: Exactly, yeah, you love miniatures.
You know you want to make a miniatures game.
It could be a component, could be a theme,
could be a mechanic, could be you want to
make a game about dog walking, whatever it
is, you're excited, what is at the heart of
what you're doing.
And in general, the heart is going to be an
experience you want to create for your audience,
but you start at something, whatever high-level
thing gets you excited.
Then framing is a lot what we talked about.
We want to put a box around it.
We want to put constraints around it.
And so that constraint should always include
a deadline, ideally a short deadline to whatever
your next step is.
So I'm going to have a prototype to test in
two weeks.
It could be —
Look, one of the most common mistakes I see
game designers make, they come to me, "Okay,
I want to make a game that's Halo and World
of Warcraft and Grand Theft Auto, but all
rolled into one with a bunch of cool stuff
happening."
And these are massive games that take millions
and millions of dollars and teams of people,
and it's like, well, you've never made a game
before.
Maybe let's start with a simple card game.
So constraints with your components, constraints
with time.
What's the space I'm playing in?
Step three is brainstorming.
And brainstorming is where you ideate and
come up with your ideas.
And I'm very particular about how I recommend
people brainstorm.
And this comes from research from the Wharton
School of Business and work that I've done
with them.
But the basics are three phases.
And to get really granular, because I know
that your audience likes that, I break it
into three steps, 20 minutes each.
First is where you are open exploring, you
write as many things as you can, as many ideas
as you can, and don't stop.
There's always this critic part of our brain
that's like, "No, that's stupid.
No, that won't work."
Turn that off.
Just write down as many things as you can.
If your pen stops moving for more than 10
seconds, you're doing it wrong.
As many ideas as you can on the paper.
Then the second stage, also recommend 20 minutes,
is organizing where you take this massive,
ridiculous, some cool ideas, some ridiculous
ideas, and you start to try to find patterns
between them.
And if you're trying to make something specific,
you start to think through, okay, if I'm trying
to make a game, what's the victory condition?
How do people figure out what are their moves?
How do they interact?
You start trying to put some structure around
it.
Or if it's a book, okay, what's the book?
What's the opening of the book?
How are people — how's it going to help
people?
Who's my audience?
Whatever it is, right?
And then as you start making these connections,
you're naturally going to see gaps and you're
going to fill those gaps in.
And then the last step, which is also 20 minutes,
is elimination.
And that's where you went from starting with
as many ideas as you can.
And now you want to get to as few ideas as
possible so that you can start moving to testing
them.
And so that's where you go and you'll try
to like, okay, what's the minimum amount that
I can prototype?
Which is the next step to test my idea, to
test my assumption, to test the core of what
I'm doing?
And so prototyping is exactly what it sounds
like.
Talk about an MVP or this minimum viable product.
What's the smallest thing I can do to test
my idea?
What's the easiest way I can do this?
And then step five is testing where you actually
show it to somebody, you get some feedback,
you actually figure out what's going on there.
And then step six is iterating where you take
what you've learned and then you cycle back
through the process.
And what I've learned is that the skill of
creativity, specifically with game design,
but really with anything is how well you can
kind of flow through that process and get
the most out of each loop and go through as
many loops as possible.
Tim Ferriss: All right, we're going to come
back to brainstorming in a second, but what
I want to do for people listening is highlight,
and you said this already, but I want to just
make a few notes and give a few examples.
This process can apply to almost anything.
And for instance, you want to start a podcast,
I'll use that as an example, right?
Inspiration thematically, where are you going?
What is the format that you're excited about?
What is driving you to be considering starting
a podcast, right?
Setting parameters, thinking about the constraints.
What are the constraints?
How do you keep it interesting enough that
you continue to do it, but simple enough that
you don't quit after three episodes?
And the example you gave of, "I want it to
be like Halo plus World of Warcraft plus Warhammer,"
and you're like, "Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, easy."
The reason there is an elephant graveyard
of a million dead podcasts that stopped after
episode three is they're like, "I love This
American Life and I think it's going to be
like This American Life meets Serial meets
Joe Rogan."
And I'm like, "Whoa, slow down Tex.
There's a reason the credits are five minutes
long at the end of This American Life.
Yeah, I'm not sure you realize how much goes
into making that and then brainstorming,"
right?
Coming up with whether it's guests, ideas
for questions, et cetera.
Prototyping, right?
Giving it a go.
Maybe you record as I did five or six episodes
before publishing your first so that you have
a chance to kick the tires and try to figure
out what's working, the testing you're going
to get in this case, testing with your guests,
but also with test listeners, let's just say.
And then iterating.
This also applies to books.
This also applies to really any creative project
that I can think about.
And to come back to the brainstorming for
a moment, when you are brainstorming, what
is your personal preferred method of doing
this whiteboard versus pen and paper versus
typing on a keyboard versus a tablet of some
type?
How would you like to do it?
Justin Gary: Yeah, so I am a huge fan of,
in particular, an app called Workflowy.
And it's a totally free app, and it's basically
a series of nested lists.
And the nice thing about it is it's infinite.
So I can continue to make list and sublists
and sublists and sublists and I can link pieces
to pieces.
And so I find over the years now, I've been
using that for seven or eight years, that
is my personal favorite tool, but I have used
— the important advice for people is not
to copy the tool, but whatever works for you,
whatever's easiest, flow, the least resistance.
So a lot of people like Notion, it's a similar
type of tool, but it's bulkier and a little
bit slower, in my experience.
And that speed is everything.
I don't want anything that's going to slow
me down.
So that's where pen and paper's great, but
I don't like, unless I have a giant sheet
of paper, which I do enjoy.
If it's a big, big poster board and you have
markers and bigger things, especially if I'm
working with a team.
So either a giant whiteboard or a large poster
board on the table because you can all share
the same space and see ideas form, that I
think is great.
But a small sheet of paper for me, my brain,
when it sees a page start to get full, my
brain just subconsciously thinks, "Okay, well
you don't need any more ideas.
Your page is full.
You're good."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It's like the goldfish in the fishbowl, right?
It's like, "All right, I'm not going to grow
anymore.
This space is getting a little constrained."
Justin Gary: Yeah.
So I like Workflowy because it's got that
infinite kind of growth and I can shrink or
grow nodes or I want to deep dive deeper into
this idea and link ideas together.
That's been my favorite.
Tim Ferriss: And what are some of the ways
that you like to prototype?
I'd love to know where you think people most
often get stuck — in between or after, which
step do people get stuck?
And as someone who's been, as you know, because
we've had conversations about this and you've
been incredibly helpful, thinking about prototyping
and games and design.
I've been very excited about this for a while
now.
I tended to get stuck at the prototyping phase
because, well, it's also my first sort of
rodeo with this.
But the inclination is to try to make something
that's really good and kind of polished.
I know I'm not trying to make a finished product,
but the more I have studied what you've done,
listened to the podcast, talk to people like
Elan Lee or others, the more I appreciate
how quick and dirty it is.
And also just as a reference, I think I have
a blog post about Stephen Key, who is an inventor,
product developer who's based in California,
at least he was at the time, who has done
extremely well developing toys for major companies.
And the toys are ultimately some finished
product that look great, but he will use construction
paper and newspaper to prototype.
And based on that and a description and maybe
a video of how it functions, he successfully
licensed products all the time to huge companies.
So could you speak to maybe the prototyping
phase?
Justin Gary: Yes.
And you've already hit on the core of this,
but I'll just leave it, keep it simple, stupid.
The KISS principle.
It is the tendency to overdevelop and make
your prototype super nice or not feel like
you can show it to somebody or test it without
it being super nice is the graveyard of the
most games probably of anything on the planet.
And the most ideas, frankly, in general.
So let's make this very concrete.
Probably one of the games I'm most well known
for is a deck-building game called Ascension.
Been around for 13 years.
We've got lots.
So I first prototyped that game.
There was another deck-building game, and
a deck-building game, for those that don't
know, it's unlike Magic, which is a trading
card game where you're buying packs of cards
and trying to build a deck.
In a deck-building game, you have a fixed
box of cards, you buy it like a box like you
would Monopoly, but during the game, you're
acquiring cards for your deck.
So it's like you get to play the game of building
a deck, deck-building game.
So there was another deck-building game called
Dominion, which was released.
It was the first of its category.
And I fell in love with that game.
I started playing it a bunch, but then as
I played it like 100 times, I was like, "There's
really some things I would like to see differently.
The cards are too static, there's too many
rules and resources.
I wish I could change it."
And so my first prototype of Ascension was
literally just instead of having Dominion
cards, which are all kind of laid out at the
beginning of the game, takes 20 minutes to
set up, I just shuffled them all together
and dealt them out and said, "What would a
game look like if it was randomized?"
And I played that way, and the game was not
good, but it gave me enough of a proof of
concept that like, "Oh, there's something
fun here and if I spend the time to do this,
I can now move forward."
Tim Ferriss: And just for clarity, you were
using the Dominion cards, but changing the
rules to see how it impacted gameplay?
Justin Gary: Exactly right.
And so if you can prototype using something
like a deck of cards around the house or take
a Monopoly set, I know I keep using Monopoly
as an example, whatever, most people know
it.
So say, "Oh, hey, what would this look like
if instead of going around Go, you actually
had dinosaurs that would try to eat each other
as you're moving around the board, what would
that be like?"
I'm like, "Okay, that sounds kind of fun.
Let's see what happens."
And so it's literally that simple.
So for my prototyping tools, my first round
of prototyping is just, I have a bunch of
stuff.
I have a bunch of dice and my D&D dice with
all the random signs.
I've got decks of cards, I've got random pen
and paper.
I will draw things.
In fact, when you and I worked together a
little bit, I showed you some things.
I showed you what my early sketch prototypes
look like, and they are ugly.
This is kind of, I talk about the phases of
design.
And so every time you go through the core
design loop, your questions are go from bigger
to smaller and smaller.
And as you go through it, you're going to
get more and more, like you're going to care
about polish more.
So if you're just trying to figure out where
is the fun, what is the idea, what's the theme,
what am I doing here?
It's like, imagine you're building a house
and before you've even laid the foundation,
you're worrying about the paint color on the
walls and where the furniture goes.
You're not going to get very far.
You're wasting a lot of time.
Make sure you've got a solid foundation first.
Worry about the paint color later.
And so I think a lot of designers start by
worrying about the paint color being wrong
and they're never going to finish a house
that way.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so I'm going to stand in,
I mean, this is a lazy sort of rhetorical
trick here.
So I'm going to defend the newbies, including
myself for a second, and ask a question, which
I think is actually really important, at the
very least helpful in all sorts of disciplines,
not just game design.
One of the reasons a lot of writers get stuck
or aspiring writers is that they kick out
a first draft.
It's rough, it's ugly, it's really, really
rough on all the edges.
And they compare their rough draft to the
final draft of incredible writers.
And the rough draft of those writers is invisible.
They never see that rough draft.
So what has been helpful to me, for instance,
when thinking about potentially writing comics
is seeing the original scripts and how they
were tweaked and how the concept art was modified
over time to ultimately land on what we see
in the finished product.
Because then I can see the ugly babies in
the beginning.
I'm like, "Oh, yeah.
Okay."
That's very reassuring and it gives me more
confidence to work with my ugly baby to try
to shape it into something that ultimately
is good, because if I'm comparing everyone's
finished product to my rough product, it can
be really demoralizing.
So the question is there a way for folks to
see the rough drafts of games, the prototyping
and so on, if they wanted to explore this
as an example?
Justin Gary: It's one of the reasons why I
started my podcast is to sort of unlock a
lot of that stuff for other designers, talk
about their origin stories, talk about where
they're not — the things that inevitably
fail.
You can also go, there are a variety of places
where people will have prototype testing.
Let's say you have a favorite game company
or game designers, we do this at Stone Blade,
at my company.
You can join our Discord, and then we will
periodically put playtest requests out so
that people can — because we want to get
feedback, we want to get feedback from people,
and they could see how terrible those games
are.
Now, we've already gone through a few iteration
loops before we put it out into the public.
So to see the most raw forms, I think there's
not enough of it out there.
I think it's something I really want to encourage
more of because it's really helpful.
I've been doing this for 20 years and my first
prototypes are hideous.
So if you want, I can share some.
I'll put some up on the thinklikeagamedesigner.com/tim.
Tim Ferriss: Or the show notes.
Justin Gary: Or the show notes.
Yeah, whatever.
Tim Ferriss: That's great.
Justin Gary: Because I want to demystify that
process.
It is okay.
In fact, it's better.
In fact, I'll go even further because not
only is it faster and because you don't get
hung up on making it really pretty, it's faster
to prototype, it's actually better to change.
It's easy because you need to iterate.
So if you've put a lot of time into making
a beautiful board and beautiful cards and
then you realize you've got to change a card,
you're going to feel weird about it.
Whereas if I have just some ugly cards —
Tim Ferriss: Your sunk cost fallacy is going
to come to latch onto your back.
Justin Gary: I have a card that I've messed
up, I'm just going to cross out something
on it with a marker and write something else.
And then, okay, now it's this, go, and I'll
make a little note.
The resistance to change is so much lower.
So it's actually net negative for you to invest
in making something pretty early on in the
process.
Tim Ferriss: Makes perfect sense.
So you've mentioned your company a couple
times, but last time we left young Justin
in our chronology, he was working at a game
design company.
So could you fill in the gaps for us and tell
us how you went from working for somebody
else to working for yourself?
Justin Gary: Yeah, this is a fun story and
you actually come into this story Tim, so
I'll share it.
So I moved from working on pure card games
to, I had an opportunity to lead a project
that was the World of Warcraft miniatures
game.
And this is a very exciting project for me.
I get to build something that's super cool
with an IP everybody knows.
And I had worked on it for about 18 months
and we had, the company that I worked for
was called Upper Deck.
They had made trading cards forever, most
known for baseball cards.
And they made Yu-Gi-Oh! and this Marvel game
I'd been working on, but they didn't know
how to make miniatures games.
And so they eventually just were going to
kill the project.
The executives come and they tell us after
18 months of working on it.
And this is pretty common in games, but I
had never had a project I had worked on get
killed like that.
And I was like, devastated.
My dream project, I'm going to change the
world with this game.
It's going to be incredible, now all of a
sudden, ashes.
And so I refused.
I didn't want to let it happen.
And so I said, "Listen, I don't know what
I'm doing here, but if you're going to kill
the project, give me six months.
Let me see if I can figure it out.
You've got nothing to lose."
And I was able to convince them to let me
become a project manager and try to figure
out how to make games, how to make a miniatures
game, specifically.
And so same kind of process like I did when
I first started to design, I was like, "All
right, let me talk to people who know what
they're doing.
I've already got a very clear deadline."
I talked to Jeremy Cranford, who's an incredible
art director, and I talked to the guy that
made the Dungeons & Dragons miniatures.
I just worked months and months and months,
try to figure out how to make this work, fly
to China, fly to the factory, figure out how
the plastics and paints and all this crazy
stuff.
Tim Ferriss: And making it work, just for
my clarity, is making it financially work
for the company?
Justin Gary: That's exactly right.
Financially, how do you make it work?
Because Blizzard, who makes World of Warcraft,
had very exacting standards about their miniatures.
They have to have spiky pauldrons this high
and these amounts of colors.
And nobody had ever done anything quite like
that before.
And it needs to be financially viable to make
this product for the company I was working
for.
So that's a partnership.
And so I have to go figure out all these logistics,
set all this stuff up.
Finally, and this is where I first read The
4-Hour Workweek, so this is actually was super
impactful for me in being very efficient using
80/20 principles.
And I've learned to set up auto email replies,
so people didn't bother me.
So already getting my efficiencies in it,
but I'm in this zone of just, I'm going to
finish this mission.
And then I finally go to — I have the opportunity
to speak to the executive team.
I'm going to make my presentation.
I'm going to make my case.
Is this project going to live or is this project
going to die?
And I'm just some kid who wants to make a
game and I've got to convince — so I'm there.
And I will never forget.
I mean, they had this ugly green carpet.
I'm sitting, waiting for my turn to get called
in.
The details are super stuck in my mind.
And I'm like, go down this long corridor.
And I'm like, my palms are sweating.
I go, you open these huge oak doors and it's
a huge sports memorabilia company.
So there's a Babe Ruth-signed bat on the wall
and a Michael Jordan jersey and a Tiger Woods
golf club.
And the rich mahogany conference table.
I mean, it's boardroom cliche, but it's very
intimidating for me at this time.
So I get up there, the owner's sitting in
his leather chair and staring me down, and
I'm like, I give my presentation and I'm stammering
through it, but I've done my research, I've
done my homework, and I go through the presentation
and heart's beating.
Finally, I stop and there's this pause at
the end.
I'm looking around, what do they think?
It's like CEO, CFO, all the big wigs.
And they start talking about the idea and
they start joshing around and I start thinking,
"Oh, my God, I think they like it.
I think this is really going to happen."
And then they start pontificating and they
start talking, "Oh, well there may be this
problem with this thing or this thing."
And it took me a minute to realize this, but
as they were talking, I realized that they
had no idea what they were talking about.
I had finally done enough research that I
knew they didn't know what they were doing.
And up to that point in my life, I feel like
I had just assumed that the adults in the
room knew what they were doing.
This is the same company that makes hundreds
of millions of dollars a year.
Of course they know what's happening.
And now all of a sudden that illusion is shattered.
And I started out terrified.
I'm terrified.
I mean, we're literally, this project, it's
going to cost hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Hopefully it'll make millions, or it could
lose millions, who knows?
And nobody knows what they're doing.
And so I'm like, "Oh, my God, what do we do?"
And then I walk out of that room, my heart's
beating, and I'm just like, "What's going
to happen?
How do we do this?"
And then all of a sudden, a cold splash of
water in my face: nobody knows what they're
doing.
I cannot know what I'm doing at least as well
as anybody else.
This idea that the difference between a leader
and somebody else is not like that they know
something or that they have some special access.
It's that you're just willing to make some
assertions and own the consequences.
That's it.
That's the difference.
And so then [it] finally clicked for me, the
other parts of your book, that not just this
efficiency and automation, but this idea of
defining what you want and then creating the
freedom for yourself to do it.
And so that's where I suddenly started doing
the fear-setting exercise and going through,
"What's the worst case scenario for me if
I quit and I do my own thing?"
And the dream lining exercise, which is basically,
"What is it that you really want?"
How do you define what you want?
How do you make that very concrete?
And so then that transformed like, I'm going
to get this game out the door.
I'm going to save up enough money so I have
a year of savings, and I quit.
And that's exactly what I did.
And it was a life-changing moment for me because
it was exactly that.
That's taking ownership of my future.
And again, I'm so grateful for you as a key
part of it.
And I'm so grateful for those executives because
they really opened the door for me.
And I don't pretend to know what I'm doing
all the time either.
Most of the time we're making stuff up, but
it's being conscious about that, surfacing
our assumptions and learning as you go.
It's been a powerful journey.
Tim Ferriss: So thank you for sharing that
and for saying all that you said.
And I would love to know when you did the
fear-setting and you're trying to identify
the worst case, how you can mitigate against
the worst case, what you would do as sort
of a backup plan in case the entrepreneurship
does not work out or maybe doesn't work out
at least with the first inning.
How were you thinking about that at the time?
In addition to what you already described,
which is the realization that, "Oh, my God,
almost all the emperors have no clothing.
So I think I can do that.
At the very worst, I can also do that."
How are you thinking about risk assessment
and what you would do if things didn't pan
out perfectly as you went into entrepreneurship?
Justin Gary: Yeah.
So I got very concrete.
So what is my actual minimal living expenses?
What do I need to be okay and have what I
need?
And I figured out what that number was, and
then I was like, how much time am I willing
to give myself to run this experiment to see
if I can figure it out and make entrepreneurship
work?
And I decided a year of savings was what I
wanted.
And so I focused on saving up.
So I have that cushion, because if you're
in the red, if you're like, "I don't know
how to make my next paycheck, I don't know
how to make rent next month," you can't be
creative and be free, you're making decisions
for the short term.
And I wanted to be able to make decisions
for the long term.
So step one was have enough of a cushion that
I could feel comfortable.
Now other people can do this as a side project
or after hours, whatever.
But for me, I wanted space to just focus on
this.
And then the other piece was like, well, let's
assume it doesn't happen.
And after a year, I've gotten nothing and
it's not working.
I had done enough in my career at that point,
I could just get another job.
I could either be hired back at the same place
or hired at another company.
It's not like I was going to go hungry on
the streets, or if I have to live on a friend's
couch for a little while, that's not that
big a deal either.
So I went through all of those things.
I could go bankrupt, my house catches on fire,
hilariously like you did in the book.
And so that's where it highlights the same
kind of lesson as before, which was when I
quit law school.
It sounds scary.
Everybody thinks, "Oh, my God, you're such
a risk-taker."
I'm not.
I mitigate risk at every turn.
It's like when you're playing Magic and you're
trying to set up so you can't get outdrawn
on a game, I'm just mitigating the number
of ways my opponent could beat me over time.
And in this one, I could always go back to
law school when I quit law school.
I could always go back to a job when I started
this entrepreneurship.
And same thing later on when I became a digital
nomad, sold all my stuff.
It's like I could always buy more stuff.
I could always get a house again.
So I strongly encourage people to just go
through that.
If you really, really think about the worst
case scenarios, 99 times out of 100, they're
totally recoverable within a year.
It's often way less.
Tim Ferriss: And what was your, knowing how
methodical you are, you were not just hopping
out of this job with savings, with no plan.
So what was your plan?
Justin Gary: I'm sad to say there wasn't that
much of a plan.
You kind of set me up for having a master
plan.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I guess with the core design
loop, I guess you are going to be following
some version of that probably, but did you
have an inkling of what type of game or what
types of games you wanted to make?
Justin Gary: Yeah, so I knew I loved — obviously
card games were kind of my specialty.
And so I knew that that was a space I wanted
to be in, but I really wanted to create that
open space to figure things out.
And so as you mentioned, of course, the core
design loop was part of it.
I didn't have it as clearly defined as I do
now, but this idea that I'm going to try things
and prototype them and test them.
And so during the day, I would work on some
designs, make up some prototypes, and then
I would go find my friends who were still
working at the company or elsewhere to try
it out, give me some feedback and come back.
And I didn't have any ideas.
I hadn't designed a game ahead of time.
I didn't know what I was going to do ahead
of time, but I had enough space that I could
figure that out.
And then it worked out that another person
from another company contacted me to see if
I could do some contract work for them.
And so I started working on some kids toy-based
games, which was great.
And so here's another fun story.
So they knew me because they used to work
at Upper Deck where I used to work, and then
they started working at this other company
and he's like, "Hey, we need someone to help
us design a game.
Can you do that?"
And I'm just like, again, no job, no plan.
I'm just figuring it out as I go at this point.
And so I'm like, "Yep, definitely I can do
that."
"Okay, well give us a quote."
I'm like, "Okay, quote, how do I quote?
I've never quoted anything before."
So I'm like, "Okay, let me just think about
it."
All right, how many hours do I think this
is going to be?
And then what's my minimum hourly rate that
I think I should be paid?
And I am like, "Okay, that's what I'll charge,
make it easy."
And I send him the quote and he literally
laughs at my face.
And he's like, "Yeah, okay, sure.
Sure, man.
No problem."
Tim Ferriss: And you're like, "Uh-oh, wait
a second."
Justin Gary: I'm undercharging.
I still try to overdeliver, do a great job.
Next time I get another thing, opportunities,
"Okay, what do you quote?"
I doubled my number.
They still laughed at me.
It's like, "Okay, great.
All right."
Doubled it again.
That — my strategy was I kept doubling what
I asked for until I met resistance.
Until someone was like, "Hmm, I'm not sure."
I'm like, "Okay, that's what I need to be
charging."
Tim Ferriss: There's one other story, I'll
just as a side note mention, which also just
underscores the fact that part of the frustration,
but also joy of entrepreneurship is you have
to figure out a lot on the fly.
You cannot prepare for all the eventualities.
You don't know what you don't know.
And I recall, I might be misattributing, so
my apologies to the founders of Nantucket
Nectars if this is misattribution, but when
I took my first entrepreneurship class, first
and only actually, high-tech entrepreneurship
with Professor Ed Zschau, who changed my life
in so many ways, he used what a lot of people
refer to as the Harvard case study method
where you have sort of a business situation,
then a problem, and then there's a break and
you have to try to figure it out.
And then only after you've had the chance
to try to figure it out on your own as a class,
then you read the outcome and the decision
they made and so on.
And there was part of this Nantucket Nectars
story where these guys are selling juices
in Nantucket and they end up with a tiger
by the tail because their drinks become really
successful and they decide to make the shift
to retail.
And they meet with a distributor and they're
talking and talking, and the distributor's
like, "So do you have good plans for POS?"
And they look at each other, they have no
fucking idea what he's talking about.
And they're like, "Oh, we have great plans
for POS.
We've thought it through and we think we have
an excellent strategy."
And he's like, "Okay, great."
And then they leave the meeting and they're
like, "What the hell is POS?"
Point of sale.
Displays.
So it makes for a lot of good stories.
So you start to figure out your pricing by
doubling and doubling and doubling.
And just maybe you could flesh that out a
little bit in terms of you're doing this contract
work for people who are giving you specs of
some type or another.
Justin Gary: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: But you have some money coming
in the door with fewer, fewer, and fewer laughs
at your proposals along the way.
Justin Gary: Correct.
Tim Ferriss: What else is happening in that
first year?
Justin Gary: Yeah, so I'm using my kind of
spare cycles and there's this really interesting
thing, the difference between an entrepreneur
who has no employees or anything, and some
dude just sitting on his couch can be very
subtle.
Until you start really getting income coming
in and start making things happen.
So there's definitely a window of uncertainty.
Tim Ferriss: I mean even now in my life, the
distinction's pretty blurry.
Justin Gary: Right, it is.
Now I've got a team and the people, it's like,
okay, I feel like I've got a business.
But it's not an easy distinction.
And when you're trying to create something
where you don't necessarily know what it is,
it's even harder.
So what I would do is I would, in between
doing this work for hire, I would work on
just projects that I thought would be fun.
And so I would just make prototypes, try them
out, try them out on friends.
And I remember it was actually with Ascension
where I didn't make Ascension specifically
to think, "Oh, I'm going to start a company
with this game."
I made it because I really wanted that game
to exist.
I played enough of Dominion and I was missing
something I really, really wanted.
And then I showed it to a friend of mine,
Rob Dougherty, and he has his own — he actually
was the guy that owned Your Move Games, the
store, and where I used to play when I was
younger.
And I show him the game and he's like, "Dude,
you have the ball, run with it.
This is great.
Make this a thing."
And he had been an entrepreneur for a while.
And so he helped me kind of like, "Okay, no,
let's do this."
And that started down the road.
So, "This is going to be my project now."
And I started.
My early prototypes were ugly.
And I'll find a way to share them with you.
I mean, some of them are horribly inappropriate.
We had just really just rude pictures and
I won't share those, but they — just ridiculous.
It was just for fun.
Tim Ferriss: Rude pictures.
How dare you?
Justin Gary: I know.
Tim Ferriss: Continue.
Justin Gary: Yeah.
Anyway, it was —
Tim Ferriss: Imagining that's code for lots
of dicks everywhere?
Justin Gary: Well, you know, I'm not — I'll
leave it to the imagination of the listeners
on this one.
Not appropriate for public consumption.
Leave it at that.
Tim Ferriss: You know what, just to defend
my dicks comment, I will say there's a place
called Hotel Biron in San Francisco.
Great wine spot, excellent place.
And I don't know if this is true, but I heard
at one point, this is one of the first places
with a console for digital signing way back
in the day.
And the rumor was that of all the guys who
went there and bought drinks, it was like
75 percent just drew dicks as a signature,
which I thought it was pretty hilarious.
Justin Gary: Well, there's an important game
design principle I didn't talk about here,
which is the TTP, which is time to penis.
Any opportunity that you give people to create
their own thing, at some point someone's going
to make a dick.
That's going to happen.
Tim Ferriss: TTP.
I'm going to add that to my metrics.
Justin Gary: Key show notes.
I mean, so what it is, the more broader point
is anytime you allow people to customize,
you have to think, what are they going to
do with it and how does that share and how
does that build your community?
But TTP's the shorthand for that.
So it is an unfortunate reality of our society
that is just going to happen.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So you'll —
Justin Gary: I did not see this interview
going this way, I'll tell you that right now.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I didn't either.
Thanks, CØCKPUNCH Coffee.
All right, so let me try to right the ship
here for a second.
So you're talking about roughs and the prototypes.
You'll filter out some of the rude pictures
and we'll share some of that.
When you were chatting with, if I'm remembering
correctly, Rob, and you say, "You've got this,
run with this," were you at that point at
all thinking of how it fit into the potentially
competitive landscape and how it was differentiated?
Or was it just enough for it to be something
that you used to scratch your own itch and
you assumed, "Hey, if this is exciting for
me as one person who plays a lot of games,
I assume it's going to be attractive to more
people?"
Justin Gary: So three things.
One, absolutely, it has to scratch my own
itch and I have to love it.
I loved it.
I wanted to see it exist.
All of my most successful projects by far
are the things that I make for me and that
I really want.
And then I know they're going to be great.
So I think that's really important.
Two, I do not chase trends.
I hate chasing trends.
In fact, every time I've tried to chase a
trend, it's been unsuccessful.
The idea of I'm trying to build something
for some hypothetical, I think this is hot
right now, has never worked.
However, there's a third point here which
is important, which is it can't be just about
you.
And so the rule I like to use is I will show
the game to people and I'll prototype it and
test it.
And when people start asking me to play again
without me prompting them, that's when I know
I've got something.
So it's not just me.
That's why Rob, who I respect a lot, he was
like, "No, this is great.
Play again."
And I would show it to some other game designer
friends and show it to some other people and
they're like, "No, this is great.
Keep..."
So as you're going through, you're getting
a wider, wider sphere of feedback that's helping
you move forward.
And if your game is targeted at a different
target audience — so I make a game called
Bakugan, which is a toy-based game for kids,
obviously how much fun I have playing it is
not nearly as important as a five-year-old
or an eight-year-old.
So you have to test with your target market
in that sense.
So I don't say that target market and testing
is not important.
It is, but don't try to chase a trend.
Make something that you know is fun and that
you enjoy and then get the feedback and iterate
as you go.
And so as you get that positive feedback,
now I'm willing to invest more and more into
the product.
So now I actually am going to go and start
putting some real art on it.
And the story behind the art is, I guess it's
at this stage I can tell.
So back when I was living in Boston, I met
the guy that lived down the hall and he comes
and knocks on the door and says, "Hello."
At this time I'd just moved out of college.
So I'm like — black light posters on the
wall.
It's still basically a college doom room.
I just transported it into an apartment.
And then the guy comes back over 20 minutes
later with a bag of weed and, "Pretty sure
you guys want to smoke this, right?"
It's like, "Okay, cool."
So we hang out, we've become great friends
and he actually, it turns out, he's an incredible
artist.
His name's Eric Sabee, and whatever.
We became friends.
I have one of his art pieces on my — well,
not on my wall anymore, but in storage now.
But actually it's on the wall of my dad's
place.
I didn't put that one in storage.
Anyway, so 10 years later when I'm making
a game, I'm like, "Oh man, his art was really
cool.
I'm going to call him up."
And I called him up and said, "Hey, would
you want to make art for my game?"
And I built the IP and the story around his
style because I knew I could get this batch
of art without having to pay for a whole new
artist and new things because he'd already
made it so I could pay him less.
And he was a good friend and he hooked it
up.
And so now I start bringing art into the game
and figuring out how you can use what's around
and build the lore and build a style around
what's available.
Okay, now we've made some art, now we've got
some cool-looking cards.
I'm investing a little bit more.
And then I take it to a convention called
GAMA, which is a game manufacturer's association
event.
It's like an industry insider tabletop game
thing.
So publishers and retailers and distributors
are all there.
So not a public show.
And I get a little booth and I bring my little
fake prototype there.
And I realized actually as I was going to
the show that I didn't have — in the game,
you get what's called honor.
It's like victory points basically.
And I forgot to make anything that you track,
how do you track how many points you get,
how many honor you get?
And I was like, "Oh, man, what do we do?"
And I went to a Michaels store, like a little
—
Tim Ferriss: Craft store.
Justin Gary: Craft store.
Yes, thank you.
And they had these little beads, these little
plastic fishbowl beads, and they're all oddly
shaped.
I was like, "All right, whatever.
Let's try these.
I'll just use these for the prototype."
So grabbed a bunch of those, put them in,
and we start demoing the game.
And people get drawn to these beads and they're
like, "Oh, my God, this is awesome."
Tim Ferriss: They're like pros finding a shiny
button.
Justin Gary: Yes, exactly.
They're super shiny and they come over and
they play the game.
They like the game.
It's like, "Oh, this is awesome.
These are going to be in the game, right?"
I was like, "Yes, yes they are."
This is like the POS example you gave earlier.
I have no idea how to get these things.
I have no idea how to make them.
I don't know what's going, but they are definitely
in the game.
Anyway, so that show, the response was so
overwhelming.
The people loved it.
Stores wanted to order it, distributors wanted
to order.
So now all of a sudden it's like, okay, now
I'm going to literally, I'm all in.
I literally put my entire life savings now,
all the extra that I'd saved up to print at
the time was 10,000 units of the game, which
is pretty crazy.
Probably a little over it.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like a lot of units.
Justin Gary: It was a lot of units.
Tim Ferriss: It sounds like a lot.
Justin Gary: Yeah.
Most times people are going to start a new
game, it's like you print a thousand units,
maybe 3,000.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you better hope to God
you don't have a manufacturing anomaly.
Justin Gary: Oh, dude, nightmare stories around
that for sure.
That's a whole different beast.
But again, this is not — I had worked with
manufacturers before.
I had made games working for another company,
so this part wasn't totally new to me, but
it was — and I wouldn't have put all of
that money into the — I used to joke, "If
this doesn't work, I'm going to have to build
a house out of Ascension boxes.
That's all I've got."
But I wasn't, again, just to demystify the
risk, I had gotten so much positive feedback.
I had stores and distributors already waiting
to order the thing.
So now it's like, okay, it's willing to put
the money in and take a risk.
Tim Ferriss: And also just for folks who are
unaware, I mean there are all sorts of ways
to potentially finance things if you have
that demonstrated demand.
I'm not suggesting this, you've got to do
your own diligence on these things, but invoice
factoring, if you have people who are pledging
and signing whatever it is, letters of intent
or something more binding to purchase a certain
quantity, you can use that with manufacturers
to then get finance terms.
And there are companies that independently
do this as well.
So there are ways to work around it.
My question that I want to ask next is related
to GAMA.
How many exhibitors or people with games like
yourself, game developers, were there at this
show?
Actually we don't even need to be specific
to game developers.
How many booths or exhibits were at this show?
Justin Gary: At the time, I think it was about
30.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, okay.
All right.
Justin Gary: It's not huge.
Now it's bigger, maybe two or three times
that.
It's less than 100.
Tim Ferriss: It's not gigantic.
Got it.
Justin Gary: No.
That's one of the nice things.
This kind of game industry is still a little
smaller than a New York Toy Fair is the more
big one that's like, it happens and that's
got thousands and thousands of booths and
you're spending millions of dollars to have
a presence there.
It's like a much bigger piece.
This one's a little smaller.
Tim Ferriss: So the reason I'm asking is that
in fact, if somebody wants just a separate
collection of stories around these types of
trade shows, and I think it was the New York
Toy Fair, Todd McFarlane, the legendary comic
book artist, has some stories around this
from our conversations, which are hilarious.
What I was wondering, and maybe it doesn't
apply because there were 30 tables or 30 booths,
but did you do anything to draw attention
to yourself or the game at this event?
Or was it simply enough to pay for a booth
and then assume that there would be enough
foot traffic to bring the right people to
you?
Justin Gary: So the principle you're driving
at is critical.
You need to get people's attention, you need
to find a way at these booths, even at Gen
Con, which is the tabletop, more public-facing
table convention where I actually did launch
Ascension and there's a lot more people and
a lot more vying for traffic at shows like
GAMA, anywhere, or even on a store shelf.
Why is someone going to stop and pay attention
to what you're doing?
The great thing about where we are in our
modern world is it's easier than ever to make
stuff.
You can print your own books, you can print
your own games on demand, you can make anything
you want.
The downside is we're flooded with stuff,
not surprising.
And so how do you separate from the crowd?
How do you draw people's attention?
So at GAMA, I mean, I already told you by
accident almost, the shiny beads helped.
Nobody had those shiny beads.
That was a really attractive thing.
But I also invested in a video drop.
I had a TV screen and I made a little cool
rotating loop showing the things.
Most people there didn't do that.
And so finding something that draws people's
eye and brings them in.
So it can be a cool unique component.
It can be a cool giant visual.
I had a game I launched years later called
Bad Beets, B-E-E-T-S.
It's a kind of play on the poker term of bad
beats, but with actual beets.
I had someone dress in a giant beet costume.
I put one of my team members into a giant
beet costume.
And yeah, it's gimmicky, but it worked.
So if you have a great product, it doesn't
matter if nobody ever looks at it.
And also all the gimmicks in the world won't
help you if you don't have a great product.
So step one, have something great.
Step two, have a reason for people to pay
attention to you.
Tim Ferriss: The workshopping attention grabbing
in real life I think is really undervalued
in today's increasingly digital world.
And this applies to, for instance, workshopping
book material by giving speaking engagements
even to a very small group.
You'll figure out very quickly what works
and what doesn't, what's confusing and what
isn't, what people will remember versus what
they immediately forget or didn't even pay
attention to in the first place.
And the trade show stories are bringing back
memories because I recall back in my former
life had my sports nutrition company and I
would go to these trade shows.
And as you know, I have to imagine this is
true for these other trade shows.
Once you get there, you are a captive audience.
And if you want a chair, it's like, oh, yeah,
you can rent a chair for 300 bucks for a day.
And I was just going in somewhat naive because
I paid the exhibitor fee and I was like, "Oh,
great, I'll figure out the rest.
Shouldn't be too bad."
But it was pretty bad.
So I remember trying to figure out how to
draw attention and at one particular trade
show, I had next to no budget, because there
were a couple of things that were mandatory
that you had to rent, which struck me as a
little bizarre, but it exhausted my budget.
So what I ended up doing was also getting,
I bought a TV at Best Buy, a big screen that
I could return, and I put on highlight reels
of Muay Thai kickboxing because it's definitely
going to grab some attention.
But to provide a little context, it was a
strong man/sports event.
It was kind of like the Arnold Classic in
Columbus.
For people who might know that, that's a huge
event.
This was much smaller, but there were a lot
of athletes and competitors and so on milling
about.
And I also brought, I think it was four or
five of these hand grippers called the Captains
of Crush, which are incredibly and increasingly
difficult to close depending on the poundage
to the extent that some of them are so difficult
that there are maybe five or six people or
12 people in the world who at that time could
close whatever the highest-rated Captains
of Crush was.
So I laid those out for people to test with
all these athletes milling about, and then
put this video up, ended up getting the couch
and chairs at a Goodwill, and I had to bribe
a guy to help me with this truck to get it
over.
Justin Gary: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It ended up being a really hilarious
experience, but it taught me a lot about what
worked and what didn't.
And I was able to iterate because it was a
multi-day event.
And taking a step back for a second, and then
I want to come back to Ascension and all the
adventures there.
What have you learned about good playtesting
or good playtesting versus not terribly effective
playtesting?
And what I mean by that is when you're providing
your game to people, certainly one pass fail
is do they want to play it past the point
that you need them to play it?
That's sort of like the Viagra test.
They send it out to test patients for whatever
it was, hypotension, hypertension, something
like that.
And then lo and behold, all of these guys
over the age of X didn't want to send back
their medication.
And it's like, huh, interesting.
Let's look at that.
And that's how Viagra came to be in its current
iteration.
But there's that, and the reason I'm asking
this, I know this is going to be a very long
paragraph question, is that when I am doing
the equivalent with my books and chapters,
there are definitely better and worse ways
to elicit feedback.
If you're like, "What do you think of this
chapter?"
It's a crapshoot.
And if people are trying to be nice, which
comes down to who you select also to be your
playtesters, in my case proofreaders, you're
going to get a bit of a scattershot of responses
and it might not be actionable.
But if I ask, "Read this chapter, tell me
the 20 percent that I should absolutely keep
no matter what."
And if you then tell me the 20 percent, if
you had to cut 20 percent that you would cut,
you're going to get very, very different type
of surgical feedback.
Similarly to someone who's maybe less experienced
as a reader, you could just say, "Note any
place that is confusing or where you find
your mind wandering," and then that gets you
to also stuff that you might cut.
What have you learned about eliciting feedback
or evaluating feedback when you're letting
people test a game?
Justin Gary: Yeah, that's a great question.
So it's going to depend upon the phase that
you're in.
Every time I go through the core design loop,
I like to think of myself like a scientist.
I have some hypothesis that I'm trying to
test, and that's what I'm focused on in that
testing session.
So when you're early on, you're like, is this
even fun?
Is this idea of rolling dice to try to punch
somebody and making combos fun or whatever
it is.
You want to just see, "Is it fun?"
I'm not asking, "Is it balanced?"
I'm not asking, "Is it pretty?"
I'm not asking, "Does the game last too long?"
I'm asking, "Is this part fun?"
And that's what I'm focused on.
And so I know when I'm testing that if I start
getting feedback on these other parts, I'm
not worried about that.
I can set that aside, because that's not what
I'm looking for here.
And the whole, I want to keep playing, I want
to play again test, the Viagra test as you
put it, that's not going to come true until
later on in the cycle.
Your early prototypes are most likely not
going to meet that, so you're looking for
other things.
So I do, like you, I have a questionnaire
that I'll use.
I have, it's up to for free on thinklikeagamedesigner.com/media,
or we can link it in the show notes, which
has a bunch of specific questions.
You can just print it out and use it.
So I will ask, "All right, what are the three
things you liked the most about the game?
What are the three things you liked the least
about the game?
Where did you get confused?"
And much like your book question, you really
want to pay attention to where people get
lost and confused.
And nonverbal communication is at least as
important as anything they're going to write
down and tell you.
Because people, if you say, "Give me the three
things you like the most, three things you
like the least, what would you change?"
Whatever.
People will say something to you just because
they feel like they have to say something
to you.
It doesn't always mean that's really what
they feel.
You're prompting them to it.
So you have to use your intuition to say,
"A, is this relevant to the hypothesis I'm
trying to test and the stage that I'm in?
B, does this align with what I see visually
of what they're doing?"
My mom tells me she loves all my games even
when she really has no idea what's going on
in some of them.
She's very nice.
But if I see that somebody's getting lost
or leaning back or checking their phone, watching
for those nonverbal cues is so important.
And you sort of train yourself over time to
get better at that.
But so asking questions to prompt for the
specifics, being focused on what's important
to me right now, looking for nonverbal cues.
And then in best case scenario, just like
you mentioned, you have some more sophisticated
readers and you have less sophisticated readers,
you have more sophisticated game players and
less sophisticated game players.
So if you can test with other game designers,
they're going to be better at zeroing in on,
"I don't care that the card doesn't have pictures
on it or that the numbers aren't balanced.
I know what you're looking for and I can give
you feedback assigned to it."
If you just take it to somebody, just a regular
person, they're going to get hung up on a
lot of little things.
And so their feedback's a little bit harder.
You have to parse out a little bit more of
what's important.
Of course, as you get more and more focused
on the final product, somebody that's in your
target audience, their feedback matters a
lot.
And then the last thing I'll say is a quote
that I think is also one of your favorites.
It's definitely one of mine from Neil Gaiman.
"When your reader says that something is wrong,
they're almost always right.
And when they say how to fix it, they're almost
always wrong."
I don't know if I'm butchering it, but that
is 100 percent true in games too.
If you're testing with multiple people in
your target audience that are consistently
saying that something's not good, you as a
designer have to fix it.
They definitely do not have the right answer
for how to fix it.
That's your job.
But that's another key part when I'm testing
is that, I'm looking for themes, looking for
patterns.
One person telling me they don't like something,
maybe I can dismiss it, but if 20 people that
are all in my target audience say that, that's
something I've got to focus on.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
No matter how pretty the paragraph, no matter
how shiny the fishbowl pebble you might have.
Justin Gary: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: If a bunch of people are saying,
"I don't get it, it's confusing," you've got
to cut it.
Not always the easiest thing.
So what happened with Ascension?
So you have enough Ascension kits to build
a house, at least you put in the order.
Justin Gary: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: And what unfolds?
Justin Gary: So then I go and I get a booth
at Gen Con as mentioned, and this was where
I'm going to have the unveiling.
And now again, I'm very poor at this point.
Tim Ferriss: Now, Gen Con, for folks who don't
know, can you just maybe paint a picture or
an analogy for what Gen Con is and the significance
of Gen Con?
Justin Gary: Yeah, so Gen Con is the tabletop
and role-playing game mecca of the United
States, possibly you could say the world.
It's from Lake Geneva is where it started.
It's why it's called Gen Con.
It's not there anymore.
But that's where it came from, where the original
Dungeons & Dragons people got together and
played.
It was the first place where people gathered,
and it kind of built this core of what gaming
became today.
And so now it happens in Indianapolis, it's
like 60,000 people every year, somewhere in
that neighborhood.
And every type of game you can imagine, people
are playing all hours of the night.
They call it the best four days in gaming,
but it's got anything you can dream of is
there and many things you can't dream of.
So it's kind of the place to be, if you will,
for tabletop and role-playing game nerds like
myself.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so you show up at
Gen Con.
Justin Gary: All right.
Tim Ferriss: You've gone from 30 booths to
God knows how many, right?
Justin Gary: Yeah, can't count how many, and
I'm just a little guy.
I have no company.
Tim Ferriss: You're at a Taylor Swift concert
now.
Justin Gary: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
And so what I had was I bought a 10 by 10
booth, which is the smallest booth you can,
10 foot by 10 foot booth.
And then they had a newbie competition, a
little submit your marketing plan and we can
give you a 10 by 20 booth for the price of
a 10 by 10.
And I won that contest.
So fortunately, I got a 10 by 20 booth, which
is still very small in the scheme of what's
there.
And I set up my stuff.
And people had started to hear about my game
because I showed it off at GAMA before, and
I start kind of putting it out there in whatever
way I can.
But this is just posting online and sharing
with friends.
I don't have any marketing budget or anything
like that, but I'm posting and whatever I
can get.
And then I get there and not only do have
— we had some of the early adopters who
had heard about it run to the booth, but then
they play the game and they loved it so much,
they would then take it, open up, buy it,
open it up, and then start showing it to their
friends.
They would set up.
And so we ended up — this is not allowed
at Gen Con anymore, by the way, but they would
just take over nearby tables at the seated
area and just start demoing the game for me,
totally for free.
Didn't ask them to, didn't pay them —
Tim Ferriss: The Ascension splinter cells.
Justin Gary: It did.
And I would start seeing people play it in
the halls, and then I would see people carrying
boxes around.
And so it became this kind of viral, before
this sort of viral sensation, in a way that
it was very exciting.
It was a very incredible moment.
And so we sold out of everything we brought.
So this is a very rewarding, very cool experience.
My team, it's not just me now, I've got other
people there working really hard to make this
come to life.
Team is like four of us.
And then I got an offer that was very difficult
offer to refuse.
So at this point, I had early product that
was shipped for Gen Con, but the rest of the
stuff was still on the way.
So I still haven't sold these 10,000 units
with all my life savings tied up into it.
And I get a call from another very, very big
gaming company, and I don't think I'll say
the name just because I don't know.
Anyway.
And they say, "Hey, we like your game.
We want to buy it out, all of it.
We'll take it over.
It'll be our game.
We'll pay you a royalty.
You don't have to worry about anything.
It'll be all done."
Now, this is a very tough moment for me.
This is, in a sense, it's a dream come true.
They buy all the stocks.
So my money's off the table, they are a big
company, they can push it, they can sell it,
and then I can just go back to making games
and I'll have some amount of royalty and that'll
be good to go.
And I sat with it, and at the end of the day,
I was like, this is my baby.
I've worked so hard to get it here, and I
want to see it through.
I want to see it through.
I want it to stay mine.
I didn't want to sell it off.
And I said no.
And it was one of those, I might regret this
one later.
And then 30 days later, product shows up finally
after delays.
Funnily enough, the product launch delay was
launched such that it actually launched while
I was at Burning Man, which was not supposed
to be, but there it was.
And when I come back from Burning Man — so
I have a little release party out in the middle
of the desert on the fly, and when I come
back, we'd sold out, everything was sold out,
the entire run, and we had to make a reorder.
And it was like, the company's working.
I can reorder, start making expansion.
And the rest of the company's history kind
of evolved from that in a way that, well,
I'm glad I made the decision I did.
Tim Ferriss: All right, many questions.
So at Gen Con, how many games did you sell,
roughly?
Justin Gary: Oh, man, I don't remember exactly,
but it's the hundreds.
Tim Ferriss: Hundreds.
Justin Gary: Some number of hundreds.
Tim Ferriss: So I want to bookmark this.
This is not going to be my first question,
but just how you sell 10,000 after selling
a few hundred?
Was it word of mouth online?
Was it something else?
Just what factors do you think contributed
to that, because it's not an immediate obvious
outcome, right?
Justin Gary: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: At least not for me listening
to this story.
But before we get to that, because this all
undergirds a lot of what you're talking about,
how do the economics of say tabletop games
or card games work?
What's the kind of traditional model?
How do people get paid?
Who's getting paid?
What are the percentages?
Is terms of royalties?
What is that a percentage of?
Could you just give us an overview of what
the economics of that world look like as a
template?
Justin Gary: Sure.
So when you're producing games, most of the
time you're going to produce them overseas.
So now with cardboard stuff, it's starting
to become a little bit more economical to
do it stateside.
We do some of our games stateside, but mostly
do it overseas.
And whatever the retail price of the game
is, you typically need — the cost of the
game has to be about a fifth of that,.
And the reason is that as a manufacturer,
you are going to sell the game to a distributor
at about 60 percent off the price of retail.
They're going to sell it to a retailer at
50 percent off the price of retail.
So they've got a 10 percent margin for distribution,
and then the retailer has that 50 percent
margin for the rest of it.
Tim Ferriss: So if you're manufacturing, if
you were a game designer and manufacturer,
then it sounds like 20 percent margins generally
on games, something like that?
Justin Gary: Yeah.
Now, if you're a game designer, typically
if you have an external game designer and
you pay a royalty to that designer off whatever
you're selling.
So if you're selling it to distribution, you
sell a percentage off the distribution price.
If you sell it direct to consumer, you sell
off to consumer price.
And that can vary depending upon the designer.
In tabletop games, typically it's going to
be anywhere between six and 12 percent at
the high end.
For more mass market games, big scale games,
it could go as low as two percent or three
percent, but somewhere in that ballpark.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, I got it.
This is important, because it highlights how
challenging your decision to say no was.
Because we're not talking about, I'm keeping
90 percent of — well, I mean maybe with
direct-to-consumer you are, but it's not like
90 percent margins versus six.
It's like there's actually a narrower gap,
which is also true, for instance, in books
for self-publishing and traditional deals,
people think they're miles and miles apart.
In some cases maybe they are, but when you
start to factor in all of the costs, the delta
between the percentage that you take, say
self-publishing versus traditional, it's not
as wide as people might think.
So thank you for giving that.
Is there anything else you'd like to add to
that?
Justin Gary: Yeah, well, it comes down to
it was a little bit more than just the money
and the dollars in the sense of it.
It was a matter of like, this was my baby,
this is my IP.
You've worked with publishers where they now
take over the rights of stuff and you can't
just do what you want with the book anymore.
You can't do things —
Tim Ferriss: I would imagine if you want to
do Ascension expansion packs or Ascension,
A, B, C, D, and E, you want to do a whole
derivative line.
If the publisher owns those rights or effectively
owns those rights, you're in a tight spot.
Justin Gary: That's right.
And now think about where we are now, 13 years
later, there's over 16 standalone expansions
for Ascension.
We made Ascension Tactics, which is an Ascension
miniatures game, which we did another expansion
to that.
Ascension's been featured in a major motion
picture.
We are working on trying to take the IP and
make cartoons and make other things, comic
books out of it.
There's all of these things that are fun.
We've had conversations about this sort of
stuff.
It's fun to create and grow and expand your
storylines.
When I first made Ascension, I had sketched
out a three-year story arc of what the world
of Ascension would be if I got the whole thing
done.
And now of course, it's 13 years later, so
I've had to make some more stories since then.
But that's the part I love.
Just like when growing up playing Dungeons
& Dragons, the process of coming up with the
stories and making it and bringing that world
to life is just, I love it.
And so I didn't want to lose that.
For people that are listening, that are trying
to make these decisions, it's not obvious.
Even though I've been fortunately successful
with it, it's not obvious that it's the right
decision for everybody.
I spend way less of my time just designing
games because I'm running a company.
I have to manage logistics, I have to manage
people, I have to plan out the marketing strategies.
There's all these things that come with running
a company.
And so I think a lot of people would actually
be better off, if all you want to do is make
games, then selling to a publisher is a great
strategy.
I wanted to build worlds and build something
bigger.
And so here I am.
Tim Ferriss: And I'll just repeat a name I
mentioned earlier, Stephen Key.
I don't think he does what some people would
refer to as venturing, which is basically
building the business to do it mostly yourself
or a lot of it yourself.
He loves developing new toys and new products,
and he's really good at the licensing game.
And that, as far as I know, maybe things have
changed, but that's the game game he plays.
And I would say just on the do something bigger
side, there are different ways of doing something
bigger.
So if you want to have the freedom to do the
extensions and so on like you have, on some
level you almost certainly have to retain
rights.
But for a product developer who doesn't have
the business knowhow or doesn't want to develop
it, doesn't want to spend time that way, licensing
to a gigantic company that has a global footprint
and distribution could be the perfect path
or the best available path for making a large
impact in terms of distribution and having
some type of — putting a spin on the ball
of culture.
Justin Gary: Yeah, speaking of putting a spin
on the ball, the game Bakugan I mentioned
earlier, is a game that I work on that's Spin
Master, the company that owns it, they have
toy plastic balls, and there's a game that,
I designed the game, but they own the rights,
they own the game, they own the distribution,
they do everything.
And that is by far the biggest game I've ever
worked on.
I mean, it's all over the world.
It's in toy stores.
Anywhere you go, there's a cartoon, multiple
cartoons.
It's enormous.
And so that is also fun and also a really
cool, exciting thing.
And so that path is totally viable.
So you can do work for hire, you can create
projects and sell them and make a royalty.
You can launch and publish your own things.
There's an enormous number of ways to go forward.
And a lot of it comes down to just getting
clear, defining what it is that you want,
what's important to you, it's like, "How do
I make a living as a game designer?"
That's like the surface level question, how
questions are a trap.
You need to get below that.
It's like, "Wait, what does it mean for me?
What is it I actually want?
What does success look like for me?"
Then even deeper than that, "Why am I doing
this?"
Because I want to make super cool worlds,
and I want to grow into a universe, or because
I want to collaborate with people, or because
I want to reach millions of people, or because
I just want to have something to play with
my friends and do something on the side.
Those questions, there's no wrong answer to
any of those questions, but if you don't dive
deep enough for yourself, you're going to
end up chasing down a path, like I did many
times, where I'm just going to compete, or
move on a path for the sake of it, because
I want the most dollars.
The most dollars is the wrong game to play,
I'll tell you that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
It can lead you astray really quickly.
Important to keep your eyes on the cash flow,
but also —
Justin Gary: Oh, yes.
Tim Ferriss: It can be a trap.
Justin Gary: Don't run out of dollars, but
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, don't run out of dollars.
Justin Gary: But don't just optimize for dollars.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so maybe this ties
in.
You've mentioned a number of successes, do
you have, in your entrepreneurial journey,
after starting your company, any favorite
failures or near-death experiences, or anything
like that that you can describe?
Justin Gary: Oh, yes.
Oh, yes, I can.
The life of an entrepreneur is definitely
one that has a lot of ups and downs, as many
of your guests can attest to it.
You can attest, I'm sure.
So what I mentioned earlier, the game SolForge,
we originally — we've since relaunched it,
but at the time it was a purely digital trading
card game, and I partnered with Richard Garfield,
this is the guy that created Magic: The Gathering.
This is a dream come true for me.
I'll tell you the brief story.
So we meet, we're at a game conference, I'd
seen him around before, but we hadn't really
met.
We're at a game conference called PAX Dev,
it's like a developer conference, and he's
giving a talk on design, so of course I'm
in the audience listening because I want to
learn from the master.
At the end there's a Q and A, and then somebody
asks him, "Hey, what's your favorite game
right now?"
He says, "Ascension," and I literally jump
up out of my seat from the back of the audience
and go, "Woo-hoo," like a stupid kid.
Everybody laughs, but it gives me the opening,
and so I go and I start a conversation with
him after the talk.
We start talking and we get excited.
It's clear we're both excited about the same
project, and so SolForge is born.
Now, this was a project that was my first
digital game I'd ever done, and I was a little
cocky at this point.
I won't lie.
I'd succeeded, my first project, Ascension
was a huge success.
Everything I touch turns to gold, it's all
going to be great, we're doubling in size
every year.
We do a crowdfund, and I thought it was going
to cost $250,000 to make that game.
We crowdfunded with that target, and we ended
up crowdfunding double that goal, almost double
that goal, like $500,000.
It's like, "Oh, this is amazing.
We're going to crush it.
We're so good."
As it turns out, making digital games is very
expensive, and it turns out that that cost
$3 million to make.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man.
Justin Gary: So I had to go and try to raise
funds again, and we have to launch the game
before we're ready.
Again, we have followers, we have cash, but
the cash burn is — over time I can see the
cash burn is higher than the income, and it's
not working, and I overextended.
I started borrowing more money, I start trying
to like, "I know I could make this work.
I'm not going to let it go.
This is my baby.
I'm going to keep it going."
Tim Ferriss: How are you raising and borrowing
money?
If you don't mind adding a little more detail.
Justin Gary: Yeah.
So it starts off with we just do a kind of
friends and family convertible notes kind
of round, so that means they give me a loan,
and then in theory it turns into equity over
time.
Tim Ferriss: Into equity.
Justin Gary: Yeah.
Then after that, then I start taking some
of those refactoring loans like you talked
about, so I'm getting loans against my future
income on Ascension to pay for SolForge, and
then starting to run up credit cards, and
all the things you really are not supposed
to do.
I get to a point where I have to finally realize,
"Wow, I'm going to go bankrupt.
I can't do this anymore.
I'm going to lose everything."
This was just one of the hardest things that
I have ever faced, because not only is it
like I feel like I owe it to my team, who
I'm going to have to lay off these people
whose livelihoods depend on it, we have fans
and people who love the game, and not only
is this — in a traditional tabletop game,
if I stop making Ascension, let's say, you
still have your copy of Ascension at home
and you could play it for as long as you want,
it doesn't matter if I don't make anymore.
But when I stop making SolForge, it's a digital
game, that means the server is turned off,
that means your entire collection is gone,
that means you can't play it anymore, everything
you spent, it's all gone.
I'm like failing myself, I'm failing my team,
I'm failing the fans, everything, and I have
to make some very, very hard decisions.
Tim Ferriss: Not to mention the friends and
family.
Justin Gary: Of course, yeah, people — I
literally have — my parents had taken a
loan against their house to help me at one
point.
I am so overextended.
I am so in the thick of it, shame and — it
is tough.
I have to come to a realization, and come
to the other side of it where I had to go
through this process of accepting.
I had to get to the other place like, "Okay,
it happened.
I've lost everything.
I failed, now what?"
Right now, this is a different kind of fear-setting
exercise because now I'm on the other side
of my worst nightmare.
It took me a little while, but it's like,
"Okay, you know what?
I will still be alive.
I will be able to pay off some of these debts
over time with some other things.
I can recover from this.
It's going to be okay.
The people who got laid off, they're going
to get another job."
It was not easy, but then once I accepted
that worst case outcome, and then I was able
to say, "Okay, now how do I make this less
likely?"
So I had to lay people off, but I also renegotiated
debts, and negotiated payment plans, and reduced
our overhead, and took on more contract work,
and slowly but surely I was able to dig myself
out of the hole.
I don't think there's any chance I would've
been able to do that if not for being mentally
ready with, "Okay, I've lost it all, I'm talking
to bankruptcy attorneys," and that gives you
a different kind of attitude and approach
when you're trying to — you're negotiating
with a lender that you owe money to, and they're
like, "You owe me money, you should collect,"
I'm like, "I know, but either I'm going to
go bankrupt and you're not going to get anything,
or we're going to work something out, and
I'm going to do my best to pay you off."
Fortunately I was able to turn that around,
and it was not only did I learn — the important
lesson is you can go through a lot, and you
can recover from it, but also to not put myself
in that position again, not to overextend
to that degree, and learn to make smaller
bets, and grow as you can.
It was a very important and powerful thing,
which then of course, I'm now been able to
come back to with reinvigorating that very
same game.
Tim Ferriss: So to ask a question related
to that, you have this dream come true partnering
with Richard to create this game, how did
you two communicate, or what led to the ability
to maintain that relationship and now work
together again?
Because there are, I suppose, as I'm imagining
different ways this could have played out,
I'm sure there are ways with many different
collaborators, where things could have exploded,
and it would've damaged the relationship,
and that would've been the end of that.
So why didn't that happen?
Justin Gary: You've got to be honest with
people, that's really what it comes down to.
Act in integrity when you work with partners,
sometimes you have bad news, you tell them
bad news.
Have some humility around when your ideas
are not working, or when you're trying things
and say, "Here's what we're going to do, and
here's what…"
When I talk about nobody knows what they're
doing, when I realize the other executives
do it, I don't hide the fact that I don't
know what I'm doing.
I've learned a lot, I've got good ideas, I've
tried things that work, but whenever you're
pushing the boundary and trying something
new, sometimes it's not going to work.
So when you're working with somebody, and
again, fortunately Richard has been — he's
a professional, he's not only has he made
games that were uber successful, but he's
also made plenty of games that weren't uber
successful too, so he knows this.
Anybody that's done this for long enough,
any creative field you cannot predict.
Everything is not going to be a hit.
So when it's my first major failure, for me,
it felt like the end of the world, but the
more you work with professionals, the more
you realize that that's just part of the process.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
What have you learned or what decisions have
you made related to your company or entrepreneurship,
how you run things, that you think are worth
mentioning?
It could be after that experience, it could
just be in general, maybe ways that you have
simplified things or challenged assumptions,
turned things upside down, anything at all
that comes to mind.
Justin Gary: One of the things that I've realized
is that the same way you design games, designing
a great game and designing a great company
are not all that different.
In a great game, you have clear goals, you
know what you're trying to do, it's very clearly
defined what you're trying to do.
You are getting a lot of feedback, and rewards,
either that be from points for achievements
or [inaudible].
You're getting constant feedback loops.
The challenge level is appropriate.
You're focused on learning one thing at a
time.
The skill level is appropriate where you want
to be.
Probably the most important thing about games,
when we play games, we take a certain kind
of mindset, if I'm playing a game, I expect
to lose, I expect to have challenges.
In fact, that's the whole point, if you play
a game and there's never a challenge, why
are we even doing it, right?
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Justin Gary: So I have tried to cultivate
all four of those things in my company.
We set clear goals where it's like, "Okay,
we're going to try to have this metric, this
specific metric, like our email subscriber
list, we're going to try to increase it by
this amount, and here's how we're going to
do it over this quarter," or we're going to
try to get a new game in this category, that
we're going to have a prototype ready to go
in two weeks.
Clear goals.
We have something that allows us to have daily
focus and feedback.
What I love is the rule of three, I think
I first learned this from Chris Bailey, his
book The Productivity Project, but I've applied
it at every level of my company.
So what it is, is you have everybody posts
their three daily goals, what are the top
three things that I want to focus on?
Three is really important because we all have
an infinite laundry list of stuff to do, we're
never going to finish our to-do list, but
if you can finish your most important three
things, you can make an enormous amount of
progress, and we scale that to every level
of the company.
So every team we have have three weekly goals,
we have monthly goals, we have quarterly goals,
and so everything kind of scales down.
I even built this into my own personal life.
I have a thing, The Level Up Journal, which
I've made, which I've got, it just has a journal
that just — it fits in your pocket, it has
three goals, three habits, and then a little
gratitude practice.
So every piece of it, by focusing on very
few things and making those the priority,
it makes a big difference.
Then lastly, with the mindset, we set very
aggressive goals, and it's okay not to hit
them, like a game you want to win, you take
winning seriously, but you don't cry when
you lose a game.
You say, "Okay, what can we learn from this?
How do we get better?"
Start to take that attitude and approach it,
sometimes easier than others, for sure, but
cultivating that mindset and focusing on what's
important, and making sure that the goals
are clear, and everybody knows what they are,
and you're moving day to day, that's how I
structure the company.
Again, it came from just the principles of
design, applying them to what we do, and I
found it to be really powerful.
Tim Ferriss: Where do people, if people in
the company are posting, for instance, the
rule of three, their three priorities for
the day, where are they posting these?
Justin Gary: So we have a company Discord,
we have a channel in our company Discord that
everybody posts their three goals for the
day.
There's a separate one for weekly goals, separate
one for monthly goals, and a separate one
for quarterly goals, and so you can always
look back and see what everybody's doing at
any given point, if you care to, at their
main focus.
It also helps us to stay connected because
we're a 100 percent remote team now, so even
though I may not talk to a given person or
see a given person, I can quickly glance and
see what's most important to them right now.
So it keeps us all connected and accountable.
Tim Ferriss: Two questions.
The first is, is there any follow-up on those
three or is it just the act of someone publicly
stating their priorities that makes everyone
feel connected, and hopefully gives them some
felt sense of accountability that you think
leads to the better output?
Justin Gary: Yeah, let's start there.
So yeah, the daily is — there's not much
follow-up on the daily, it's about staying
connected, and I think it just forces you
to plan.
It forces you to assess for yourself, "Okay,
what actually is important to me?"
A lot of people will just start checking emails
and going down rabbit holes, and they're working,
they are working, but they're not doing what's
important, they're just doing whatever's in
front of them, and so this forces, just as
a habit it forces you to think things through.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, great point.
Then?
Justin Gary: Then for the weeklies, we do
have that, so we have our weekly goals.
We have a check in at the end of the week,
where people will post, "Hey, here were my
goals for last week.
Here's how they went.
Here are now my goals for the next week,"
or, "What can I do?
If I didn't meet a goal, what am I doing to
fix it?"
So there is some accountability, and I read
through those every week for the team.
Tim Ferriss: That's on Friday?
So people are setting their priorities for
the following week on Friday.
Justin Gary: Correct.
Tim Ferriss: Why Discord versus other tools?
How did you choose that?
Justin Gary: We tried a lot of them, and I'm
obsessed with productivity tools as you are,
I think, with a lot of these things, sometimes
to a fault.
We tried Slack.
We tried a couple of other custom ones.
We tried Asana.
We tried Monday.
We tried a bunch of them.
But the nice thing about Discord is, one,
it's very easy to use, you can just start
up a channel for free, you can have voice
chat and text chat.
You can also upload bigger files, and you
can with — Slack restricts that unless you
have a paid program, it's much easier to load
files and share things.
Honestly, Discord started as a gamer-focused
thing, and so we actually built our fan community
in Discord.
So you can go to the Stone Blade Discord,
and it's kind of funny because it's sort of
a front-of-the-shop, back-of-the-shop kind
of vibe.
It's like the front of the shop is where all
the fans are there, they're all chatting about
the games, we can jump in and chat with them.
Then we are in this private channels that
you can't see, but we're talking about making
the next things that you're going to be talking
about six months from now.
So it automatically gives us a sense of connection
to our fans, because the same place where
we're doing our work, one click away you can
see and interact with fans.
It has a nice bonus effect of making us feel
a little bit more connected to the community.
Tim Ferriss: How much of your work do you
do on laptop versus phone?
What percent would you say?
Justin Gary: Oh, 90 plus percent laptop, for
sure.
My phone is, I'll occasionally check emails
to make sure I'm not missing anything, but
I hate working on my phone.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I figured it was probably something like that,
I'm the same way.
What is the mobile experience with Discord?
I've never used it on mobile.
Justin Gary: It's fine.
Again, mostly when I'm there, I can check
messages.
I turn off all notifications for everything,
I don't want my phone bothering me, or pinging
me, or distracting me.
I'm using my phone consciously because I want
to look at something specific.
It means I have a meeting and I'm not at my
desk, I'll go to Discord, go to the meeting
thing, check it, or I have something I want
to post at a public channel.
This is another key thing about it that's
great, because you have so many different
channels and you can make threaded discussions.
One of the things I try to encourage is that
we have, as much as possible make communications
public.
A lot of times people will have side chats
and side conversations, and come up with some
great idea, and then it will get lost because
people are just in a private channel somewhere,
and so we'll make sure that people have public
discussions as much as possible so people
can add comments, and can get involved and
stay connected if they want to.
But to continue with your question, the mobile
experience, it's mostly just for some — I
will only use it if it's like there's some
specific communication, or meeting, or connection
I need to do, that's when I'll use my phone.
If I'm going to work, it's because I'm set
up at a laptop, designating time to work and
connect.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
We could keep going for hours, and maybe we
will do more rounds, but there's a prompt
here that I would love to explore, which is
how a trip to Thailand helped you to escape
your need for control.
As someone who focuses on systems, predictability,
controllability, et cetera, this might be
therapeutic for me to hear.
So could you unpack this for us?
Justin Gary: Yes.
Yes.
I think we're very similar in the sense, Tim,
it's not — I wouldn't call myself a control
freak just because I don't want to say mean
things about myself, but I very much want
things to be good, and I believe I know how
to make them good, and I want to make sure
that they are good.
So that's what control freaks say.
But the point being like, "Look, I know I'm
good at my job, and for the most part, with
most of the jobs that people are doing, I
know how to do them as well as they do, that's
how I know if they're doing a good job or
not."
This is the story I'm telling myself.
I hired a lot of very smart, very capable
people, and I ended up, every extra person
I hired suddenly became more work for me,
because I had to keep checking to make sure
that they were on track, or setting up more
systems to have this, if they weren't doing
something the way I thought they should be
coming in, or they would come to me with questions.
At some point I'm like, "Listen, this is too
much.
This has gone kind of crazy.
I need to step away."
So I said, "Look, I'm going to take a three-week
trip to Thailand.
I'm not bringing my laptop.
I'm not reachable.
I'm going to do that in six months."
I gave the team plenty of time, "What do you
need from me?
How do we set this up so that you don't need
to talk to me?"
They, "Okay, we need access to these things
that only you have access to.
We need to know this, whatever."
It was very little as it turned out, and then
I go to Thailand.
Now, I am still too much of a control freak,
so I really did bring at least my iPad with
me so I could check in, but I didn't respond,
I didn't do anything.
What magically happened is everybody just
stepped up, and they answered the questions
that they would've asked me themselves because
they were perfectly capable of doing that.
They started taking initiative, and building
new things, and doing stuff that I didn't
even think to do.
I realized, with some embarrassment, that
I had been holding them back, that I had,
by not allowing them to fail, or do things
that would be different than I would, I had
been constraining them from becoming leaders,
and doing the things that they should be doing.
I had built work for myself, I had made them
less effective at their job, and I had made
my life less good.
So that was one of the best vacations I ever
took, because it actually really changed the
entire way that I managed, changed the entire
way I viewed leadership, and I love Thailand.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
Just building the systems that then persist
after you get back, what a liberating experience
that must have been on so many levels, the
gifts that keeps on giving.
Justin Gary: Yup.
It's something you talk about a lot, and it
cannot be underestimated.
What is it?
So you asked the question, what would it take
for me to let go?
What would have to be true for you to be willing
to not get into this?
It could be some key metric that you care
about that they have to report.
It could be that they have to stay within
a certain budget.
It could be that they're — in reality, you're
just making up stories of, "Oh, well, I just
feel like I need it."
Let those things go, let people grow.
In my experience, it's just been incredible,
I now have a team that can literally run itself.
I get in, and I focus on the key new projects.
I focus on the most important things I think
are wrong, but for the most part, I have stepped
away from a lot of the day-to-day, and I have
watched my team get better and better, and
better.
Again, it's part of that mindset, they make
mistakes just like I make mistakes, and sometimes
the question is, "What do we learn from it?"
And don't make the same mistake twice.
We've learned a lot along the way, and it's
been pretty amazing.
Tim Ferriss: So Justin, we're coming up on
almost two and a half hours, two hours and
17 minutes or 18 minutes, I'll ask just a
few more questions, and then we can slowly
land this plane.
The next question is one that many long-term
listeners will be familiar with, the billboard
question.
If you could put a quote, a question, a phrase,
a word, anything on a billboard, metaphorically
speaking, to get it in front of millions or
billions of people, what might you put on
such a billboard?
Justin Gary: Yes, I'm excited to get this
one.
I had anticipated it might come up.
I've listened to a lot of the podcasts.
I'm going to use one as a mantra for myself,
which I say to myself every day, which is:
"Cultivate comfort with uncertainty and impermanence."
Cultivate comfort with uncertainty and impermanence.
It sounds maybe a little woo-woo to people,
but in reality it's so much of what we do,
and we talked about this a little bit earlier,
is because we're afraid that we don't know
what's going to happen.
We're afraid we're going to lose something,
and the truth is, you never know what's going
to happen, and you're going to lose everything.
We're all going to die.
If you can just be okay in that space of not
knowing, the control freak piece of it, the
staying as a lawyer or a safer path, and be
okay with the fact that things are not going
to stay the same all the time, then life gets
so much easier, whether that be your creative
path, or your relationships, or anything,
that has been one of the most powerful things
for me personally, so I'd hope to share that
message.
Tim Ferriss: That is a perfect place to begin
to wrap up, and that is exactly what we're
going to do.
So Justin, people can find Think Like A Game
Designer at thinklikeagamedesigner.com.
You mentioned the /media for various things.
They can find you on Twitter @Justin_Gary.
Any other websites that you would like to
mention, or places you'd like to point people
to?
Justin Gary: Yeah, sure.
You can come to stoneblade.com, it's for my
games, if you want to pick up any of my games
or join our Discord, there's a link there.
We, myself and my team, are all there chatting,
so you can chat with me on Twitter, and on
the Discord.
I love talking with people that have design
and creativity questions, always happy to
help.
This has been so much fun, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: It's such a blast.
People, take him up on it, I highly, highly
encourage you to engage.
Thank you, Justin, for taking so much time.
I'm glad we were able to finally make this
happen.
I really took so many notes, so lots to follow
up on, personally.
To everybody listening, thank you for tuning
in.
As always, we will link to everything we discussed,
and probably much more in the show notes,
tim.blog/podcast, you can just search Justin,
and I'm sure that this will be one episode
of very few, maybe the only that pops up so
you'll be able to find everything there.
Until next time, please be just a bit kinder
than is necessary, both to others and to yourself,
and with that, Tim Feriss signing off.